hey I think we're on my Khatami let me
see there it goes well it says it's on
alright
if you hear a bunch of noise in the
background it's because there's a storm
coming boertie in summer this year yeah
I'm here
well yeah that was it's like rakaia
explosion explosion I think there was a
wreck out there on the highway it
sounded like yeah cuz we just we heard a
boom and then we heard a bunch of
[ __ ] ambulance isn't well from pretty
bad on my little device it always does
that at first so yeah we decided to do a
side tracks today do a live stream and
stuff like that we don't watch any new
movies so we don't have any movies to
review but we thought we had to go
online because it's Tom's birthday today
yeah happy birthday - Tom yeah got me a
cake and everything card bought me had a
little drum practice with a drone way
out and that early though yes I didn't
know it's like I ordered it a long time
ago and it's like the package came and I
guess he didn't look and saw that look
to see if my name was on there and he
just like opened it no I heard your name
was we were expecting something else
yeah we were expecting something else we
were expecting like more lights from the
from the show yeah I had ordered those
too so he thought that if I was act so
he just opened it and then he's like who
sent us this I'm like but yeah show show
him the card that I found for I was very
very excited when I found this card you
guys
I waited stopped what is it - oh yeah
they're derecho circus look at that it
looks just like Pookie yeah Pookie with
a [ __ ] with the thing on her head
yeah and that totally looks like
something kooky would do - okay it's a
space helmet
cuz she's it's it's one of those stuck
in Chinese yeah Chinese takeout takeout
container but they gotta cut like a
space helmet yeah like I said that
totally looks like yeah I was so happy
when I saw that
looking for that yeah it is ridiculous
is that you know I saw ones that have
had cats that look like Pookie but they
had tails you know I mean they don't
have a lot of makes pictures yeah like
with a little stumpy tails they need
more representation so you ever sing
happy birthday to see who's here
hit Pookie our glorious leader lasenthal
ones mark Neko cat Sanders there yeah
Sabrina Maria Emmie Stumbo Jenny Frisch
motional landscape tough emotional and
hey you know what I answered your
question about you know is army hot why
it's not the press and not sent you a
link of a guy doing a TED talk he's a
reporter and he was with the guys up at
Restrepo and he explains why guys who go
through combat always miss it and always
want to go back to it but I sent you
that link but sometimes on YouTube you
don't get a notification that somebody
responded so just tell me yeah I've
noticed that because like I've like
answered people are had people like ask
me questions and I was like written back
but then it didn't it notifies me when
there's a new comment on things but not
necessarily a flea you know because I
usually get oh thank you very much mango
badger yeah see and everybody can we
just talk about the yummy cake that I
got for you because we had it we had to
have a piece obviously I get them from
the public's bakery you know yeah and
this one I think it's called the
limoncello or something like that it's
like a lemon cake and it's got like
fresh strawberries like in between the
layers and it's got like a really nice
like whipped cream hold on Oracle man
delicious more Oracle mom or can mom
[Laughter]
make a bear Austin is there free pixie
fire pick fire picks yeah yeah
even the glasses they do not help okay
yes emotional landscape says she'll
check it yeah it's on I was on that of
the show you remember which one it was
okay yes 26 with us right now
everybody's saying happy birthday yeah
see I knew everybody would show up and
yeah for Toms birthday how does it feel
being one year old I'm not gonna say
hello so everybody knows on 5151 [ __ ]
years of excellence yeah we're and I
know this is well it's your birthday we
don't usually drink at this time of the
afternoon because it's only two o'clock
in the afternoon for us but I was like
hell with it he's like hey you want a
drink how long are we gonna be streaming
for him like I don't know I don't even
know we're gonna talk about the he's
like hey you want some you want drinking
I was like yeah why not like I said we
cake and liquor can't ask for anything
more than that I can make some
predictions for my birthday
[Laughter]
Nostradamus predicts
rias worse says I'm 59 it's a good
decade yeah I guess I'll be finding out
in a few years I still get a couple
years to get before I get into the big
five oh I'll be 48 that's September so
we'll see how that goes
I don't know is it it's weird because I
don't know I just never felt like it
mattered all that much I guess I haven't
gotten to a point where I just like feel
super crappy every day yeah well you
don't have white hair and you don't look
like a damn dried-up [ __ ] hair not
yet hopefully help me like superzeros
about that like way past arrogant look
like my mole research chimpanzees did
they put out to [ __ ] pack I prize
I've read so many books about all the
poor little chippy of these that they
the research chimpanzee yeah well after
a certain age they have to send them out
to to pasture yeah they have to like put
them out the thing one even the the ones
that are male you can't really deal with
them after
turn eight or so because they get too
aggressive so they can't do like any
kind of like intelligent studies or like
anything like that they they do how does
a research chimpanzee live when they're
doing research on do they have a shitty
life or I guess it depends on the
facility and it depends on what kind of
research they're doing on that I mean I
think from you know cuz I was always
kind of interested in like Cape
Intelligence and stuff so from the books
that I've read in that arena most of
them were treated fairly well yeah and
actually coming up in like you know the
60s and 70s a lot of times because for a
time your reason like they were raising
them like children because they were
interested interested to see like how
similar to humans they would act if they
were raised a little children kind of
similar it is yeah it was kind of
similar I mean but like I said once they
turned eight and like they became into
sexual maturity the males were just
certainly beating people up and tear
their arms off why not as soon as you
see that little female orangutan react
to that guy's magic trick go on YouTube
[ __ ] laugh yeah I love that I love
that points out of the stars laugh and
that's what I mean it in a way that's
why I think it's like kind of terrible
that they you know put them in zoos or
they do this kind of [ __ ] to him because
I mean that's like doing it to a kid
they're about the same intelligence
level as a kid just because they can't
talk bends on the zoo yeah you know this
is the facility is good sometimes they
might have it better than they'd have it
in the wild yeah cuz they're running out
of places to live and the land can't
support them and people just shooting
them and [ __ ] selling them for me
yeah I mean I don't mind ones like you
know that have like huge enclosures and
you know that have everybody it's it's
just kind of the ones that they don't
really have that much anymore just
because we don't really you know but
there's were some zoos I remember when I
was growing up as a kid that you go to
the zoo and like they'd have like a big
tiger or something like that it was in
like this tiny [ __ ] cage like a tiny
enclosure which obviously is not an
ideal situation yeah because that's not
they don't have enough room to like walk
around you know but they don't have
enough room for them in the wild
that's true just like I said yes you
want tiger king yeah they're just you
know back
gang or lion king tiger King dad my dad
my dad here my day he hid straight got
her dance up there's a difference
between Lion King a tiger kid mango
badger says what the hell are you
drinking Tom it's uh server tequila with
rock star rock star energy drink yeah
yeah it's giving me energy
drunk energy yeah well you like that
better than or you you like that just as
much as the cuz didn't you get the
what's that other fun fun [ __ ] called
the red ball
yeah well tropical that's okay it's just
it's not really worth the price there's
rock star is a lot cheaper
rock stars a lot cheaper because you can
taste better you can get um the big can
of rock star for what was it 229 or
something like that whereas like just
for the little bottle of the yellow it's
like seven or eight bucks like just four
four little bitty ones you know I mean
yeah somebody's saying I'm causing and
curing a hangover at the same time if
only that was how it worked
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you can just
wait for the ship to take effect you
[Music]
drink it fast I'm gonna encourage it's
pretty strong is it yeah okay yeah I'm
gonna say later on this evening you're
just gonna be like wow yeah you're just
not gonna want to do anything I'm sorry
yeah
you think not sure you can take a whole
band nap later on yeah I could do
whatever I want it's your birthday you
can do as well you can do it I do
whatever I want every day you can also
ask a question you know of course you
send me money
and money I'll answer I'll answer a
question well yeah I'll make up I'll
make a prediction prediction from
Nostradamus man who saw tomorrow and the
day after that and yesterday well that
seems considerably easier yeah everybody
saw yesterday unless you're in a coma
yeah so what are what have we been up to
today like I said I went and picked up
your cake yeah got masked up and went to
the public's bakery picture and I needed
some spaghetti yeah well what do you oh
I got that you got something in the oven
what is that I don't even know what it
is it's just like I see the ovens on it
smells good in here I don't know what it
is it's a pork shoulder I took a whole
bunch of took a whole bunch of um
mustard I put about a cup of that in a
big ol bull uh-huh put about 4
tablespoons of coriander about for a
[ __ ] paprika and some garlic salt no
sound I got a consuming granulated
garlic
and then some cayenne pepper and then a
little bit of tumeric and I mixed that
in there with that mustard and I
slathered it all over the outside of
that pork shoulder oh my god put it in
there 450 degrees for about a half hour
just to brown the outside of it
then I've turned it way down to 185 I
must slow cooking yeah it's been in
there for a while yeah already probably
ready around 2 or 3 well it is you three
probably yeah cuz I think you put it in
there about 11:30 yeah yeah so this is
good about 4 hours that's a big one yeah
yeah
4 or 5 hours mark who sent you money his
question was ok when will my butthole
stop burning
it'll stop burning once you stop wiping
on it with that damn [ __ ] really hard
[ __ ] like Scott's one player but it
does not work it's just some Preparation
H stop burn it it'll stop burning once
Matt why
Zak stop staring at babies staring at
solar radiation powered by gas region
and as yet undiscovered hormones and is
the hormone that makes gay men gay
virgin it's not testosterone it's not
estrogen make some [ __ ] dance
they start dancing especially especially
when the pet shop boys are on yeah shop
boys oh yeah they get out eraser and
eraser that's right that's what it's
it's like I'm so ambivalent about gay
wave yeah we're some of it I like I've
never been a big fan of the Pet Shop
Boys I love it's a sin and there's like
a couple of other songs and there's I
like erasure I think I liked more in the
80s but then I kind of got sick of them
because they were just a little too it's
too repetitive i well it's too like
mainstream you they're so good but it's
like there's a lot of I like you know
stuff that's not quite as happy is that
yeah Tom cause my hangover this weekend
sorry okay what I should be in the
remake of home into what should I play
wow wow we need to see omen to again I
don't even remember what was that what
was that one who was in that one that
played Damian and that was up where
Damian was a teenager or like a young
man kind of
I remember the three of them being that
like one two and three actually all
being like fairly good Cheers here
what's up Junior
mmm that's my that's my that's my boy
from Mexico from TJ he's a fellow
connoisseur of [ __ ] tequila Oh
I was trying to find you yeah for
Instagram I was trying to find a picture
of a cake that looked like a tequila
bottle and well the funny thing is that
I was amazed that there were like a [ __ ]
ton of them they exist but almost all of
them were patron yeah like they're I
guess that's a thing because like a
whole bunch of different bakeries make a
cake that looks like patron I don't know
wavered but with patron I don't know I
don't know if it's like there they
always like have like limes and [ __ ] on
its maybe it's like a lime cake with
like put I don't know then maybe they
just made it look like that yeah Damon
at the military can you think about the
omen is in almond one I look like that
to [ __ ] my babysitter's always were
like oh he looks just like a little kid
I wish I could find that picture where
was that picture of you that used to be
in that frame of you as like a kid I
don't know I don't know what the hell
that was around here - yeah I looked
like I look like a little kid from the
moment yeah you look like Damon and I
did kind of look like him [ __ ] from
the in the military school phase - yeah
also you looked a little bit I guess it
was more the hair but like when you were
a teenager he kind of had like a Rick
Springfield see Thomas how yeah that's
true I kind of jokingly for a while I
was like photoshopping a bunch of
pictures of you into like pictures of
these people and I did I I found a cover
of Tiger Beat yeah that had I think I
think see Thomas house on the front but
it's like I photoshopped about and then
put you in there like in your teenage
thing and then we and then you put it on
your Facebook page like totally
pretending it was real and people
believed it was that you're a pop star
yes and then post a picture of me
photoshopped in with the very early
go-go's yeah that was my favorite one
that yeah that one came out and I
started lying underneath this yeah I
remember that one on there like - you
knew the go-go's
yeah I toured with the go-go's yeah man
those chicks tore me up I had kids I was
too young to be hanging out with them
girls man you know just all kinds it's
like Belinda Carlisle use me oh yeah
yeah
Jane Wiedlin
it was always Sauron [ __ ] there carry me
around in their suit yeah whatnot and
then she had another picture me as a kid
I must have been about seven and I was
in a STP jumpsuit yeah it looked like
something that you know mechanic and
where it said STP on and she
photoshopped me right in with [ __ ]
Evel Knievel when he was getting ready
with us for a snake carriage oh yeah and
it looked real it looked like it looked
like Evel Knievel was all things I was
talking with you baby Tom yeah put that
she put that up there on YouTube no
YouTube on Facebook and I said yeah I
remember that because that's when I was
coaching I was coaching the Knievel
right before a snake Canyon jump he's
like he asked my advice because I was
you know I was really um at that point I
had done many jumps on my big wheel yeah
yeah told us to keep his hand clear of
the [ __ ] parachute or the parachute
[ __ ] deployment latch in case you
guys don't know he had his hand on that
[ __ ] and [ __ ] when the rocket took
off the g-forces caused him to pull back
on it and he released the damn chute
what plane is still going he's lucky
that that chute just didn't tear loose
yeah because he just would have fallen
straight down yeah yeah well you know
he's good either wasn't really the
brightest man he was [ __ ] [ __ ]
brave but I don't think he really
thought a lot of this [ __ ] out well
sometimes it's better to it you know in
terms of bravery
I guess dizzy to be kind of dumb because
then you don't like overthink it you
don't think about too much about the
[ __ ] that can happen yeah you just kind
of do it without thinking about what he
did over think a lot of it though even
with what little brain he had he was
still overthinking like I respect his
[ __ ] much his mother
that's made to live and busted himself
up but he thought that he thought it he
had to be ready to deploy the chute yeah
I wouldn't worry about deploying that
she's worrying too much about deploying
the chute and he had his hands crossed
over his chest and just did the shot let
it fly let it fly and then you know once
once the g-forces Rost off of he could
have deployed it he probably would have
made it yeah I think it was gonna make
it oh well and he called it a rocket
cycle you build a [ __ ] rocket [ __ ]
and put two wheels on the body we LAN
the bottom of it called a cycle yeah
maybe didn't even have wheels on it I
can't even remember now I think it did
have some wheels on it because he had to
call it a cycle yeah yeah cuz he said he
was gonna jump it over in a motorcycle
first see and then they were like well
it's not technically a rocket yeah not
as not as you know it anyway
the first one was a motorcycle yeah the
motorcycle with wings and a bunch of
rocket engines on it but there is no way
that thing could have made it across
that Canyon though yeah no way
because I mean but he still had it he
would show people that but then later on
he says no here it is and everyone's
like ah missile yeah well he's like what
I can't really jump that far in a
motorcycle come on are you guys high
well it's like I don't know it's like I
was a kid man a real my friends on the
block [ __ ] Jimmy and Mike we all
wanted to be Evel Knievel yeah we wanted
to grow up and be stuntmen no that's not
what we called it Daredevils that's we
come we're gonna be a daredevil gonna be
a daredevil yeah
let me start man very 80s people know
what I'm talking yeah that was the thing
there was a thing of the seventies
mmm-hmm get on up get on our bicycles a
[ __ ] tie damn did all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] put my dad's motorcycle helmet on
time bath towel like that come on Hoss
[ __ ] yellow dish gloves
ride out to the [ __ ] place we're
gonna do this not going jump up get up
on top of the shed jump off the top of
the shed [ __ ] bust my head but they
were doing it with me good times yeah I
mean you know that's wait that's we did
70 eggs you just kind of ran around you
went in the woods you took bits and
fireworks and policemen [ __ ] up in that
same outfit I climbed up on top of the
house with to record album covers a
little bit of paper record on this story
put my hands and wings and didn't work
didn't work cuz remember how I said that
please tell me that one of those albums
is like fly like an eagle or so then
trying to think what else I did this
[ __ ] crazy yeah Oracle months as evil
was played by George Hamilton once big
seventies icon energy at work he was the
one that was like super tan right yeah
like it's that everybody like made
George ambien Maya [ __ ] evil can you
yeah the evil knievel toy with the
motorcycle yeah I think we're behind you
my brother had that too yeah that was
the main toy
yeah I'm sold a lot Kenner I think made
that I think they did in cuz I remember
the commercials to I think my brother
might have had it or one of our cousins
because I remember somebody having that
at our house then it was a bigger bigger
six million dollar man you could look
through the back of his head [ __ ] see
ya oh my god I still love this old
[ __ ] tool yeah I wish I still had came
with an engine block he could put in his
hand like that he [ __ ] lift the
engine block up that's a cool [ __ ]
toys back pad man I was like trying to
remember cuz I wrote a thing on oh thank
oh my gosh thank you so much delay Oh
what happened here thank you thank you
thank you babe BAM
I'm you see them flash bow thank you
very much Tom did you ever use paint or
lipstick to draw on your towel like to
maybe draw s like a Superman
what with what the towel was it was a
colored towel yeah it was wasn't a bath
towel it was a beach towel a beach towel
does her Baker yeah ever bigger and it
had something trying to member what it
was it was probably something like a
Jaa's beach towel oh I like that
remember let's say you were like it's
like a shirt which that's a weird that's
weird when you think about it you're
going to the beach it's like just look
at it and it's got a dams jaws I was
already that was seventies though man of
course that was already scared of sharks
I told you and it's like I it was
something that I always worried about
because like I said I'm like super super
terrified of like deep water and
everything even though I grew up in
Daytona Beach like right on the ocean
and my mom loved the beach so she used
to take us there all the time when we
were growing up and but it was something
I always thought about like sometimes
I'd be swimming out there but then I'd
be like yeah I think it's time to go in
it's like I just know I've been feeling
about the sharks and then later on when
I was in junior high or high school and
I took marine biology and I still
remember an aerial shot of Daytona Beach
and there was just like here's all the
little peoples in the water or whatever
and then like right there it's just like
shark just [ __ ] sharks everywhere
some of them might be dolphins but
because the Dolphins would like come
into the river sometimes but I was just
after that I was just like yeah I think
I'll just like stay in ankle-deep water
I did have a small shark like swim
against my leg one time when I was out
there and I was like okay that's enough
ocean for today thank you yeah talk
about some of these yes right in in the
in the biotic man 1 6 min time and you
could I think roll things back and take
bike implants out of his arms somebody's
talking about pulsar man I think that's
the one had to clear chest you could
pull it back and if you pump the back of
it you his circulatory system would go
through oh yeah and he had he had a red
red and black outfit like one red leg
and one black leg and one black arm and
one red arm yeah it was like a jacket I
think and I think you actually lifted
his face up and underneath there was
like a damn [ __ ] disc the
put in his face hey I can bring you back
to the memory like a computer CD yeah
for the head CDs and yeah the camera you
moved it a few tilted that look like it
was moving and look like the [ __ ]
disrespect I think that was the same to
it you might have to correct me if I'm
wrong but I think the same guy with the
circulatory system I think behind his
face you could also put a damn disc I
think I yeah I remember something like
that
Stretch Armstrong we had one of those we
had a Stretch Armstrong and we had the
one that looked like The Creature from
the Black Lagoon kinda he was like green
and scaly yeah you guys said Rama's face
night I remember that one too it was a
silver guy they had a cartoon it had a
comic book for it but I never really got
into it they never really got it ROM
they didn't quite get right though it
didn't look as cool as a Shogun warrior
yeah and then later Battlestar Galactica
came out I was getting so his bow star
Galactica toys and I think if I remember
correctly I had a big Cylon but then
later on a they had a big old [ __ ] I
had a big old Boba Fett - yeah we never
had we never got one I had the bubble we
had a [ __ ] ton of Star Wars toys because
like I said we had a lot of we had
girl toys boy toys everything like that
excite the two younger brothers one
brother who's four years younger than me
so he got like a lot of he had one of
the big a dads and yeah we had all the
little bitty like Star Wars we you know
the little ones that had like the the
diecast the lips there were just there
were little tiny and then they came with
like the little miniature sets you know
what I mean yeah we had a bunch of those
and we had some of the place that's we
had Hoth we had daga bah we had like a
whole bunch of the I had some of the
metal storm warships like they had one
of us up there's a Millennium Falcon
about the size your hand and the other
one was like a Star Destroyer that was
you know about seven eight inches six
has just long been metal yeah it was
funny because you know they were the
same size but they weren't to scale no I
mean them right like you know in
relation to each other weren't to scale
to each other yeah I didn't really like
them that much because they weren't to
scale yeah well they can't fight they
can't fight each other
it's [ __ ] crazy Tom did you ever
collect lunchboxes no those back in the
day I had I didn't really collect them
but I had one I would get like a new one
every year a new one I had I remember
having a Charlie's Angels one
I had the Dukes of Hazzard one yeah I
had a Muppets one uh I had a peanut
Swann yeah like the metal ones I think
at a Garfield one too but that one might
have been plastic when I was real little
I think I had one of those Snoopy on it
yeah because I think he was Snoopy as a
Red Baron oh that's pretty cool the one
I had was I think was all the Peanuts
characters like or Lucy and the and
Charlie Brown with the football or
something like that and by the time I
was like in the third grade I had a kiss
one nice yeah I had a friend I think I
liked my Muppet one the best I was like
I really like the Muppets I still like
the Muppets yeah I had even you remember
did you have any um Colorforms
because for some reason I really really
liked Colorforms and I had I had a
muppet set that was like the the
background was like a nightclub and then
they had like all the little like Miss
Piggy could like be up on the stage
dancin and like people be sitting there
and [ __ ] like that I had a peanuts one
of those two I had a Batman one yeah -
it's on - those I think my favorite toy
when I was a kid still and I wish I
still had it was the Weeble haunted
mansion it was like a dollhouse but it
was like a haunted house and it was like
all creaky the door creak - like when
you opened it and there was like little
secret passages and it came with a witch
which I still have even though I lost
her hat it came with a ghost - glowed in
the dark and then it came with like two
kids a boy and a girl and they were
making faces like oh my god like they
were making like scared faces um and I
really wish I think all I have left of
it is the witch and I'm really upset
because I mean I guess I can buy one on
eBay it feels like I don't know why I
just really really liked that toy a lot
cuz anything to do was like haunted
mansions and just something to the front
door oh [ __ ] Oh find the box
maybe someone delivered some stuff
Oh spider-man Colorforms yeah I think we
had that too and there was another thing
I don't even remember what the hell
these were called but I used to get him
like at the convenience store like next
to my grandma's house but they were kind
of like Colorforms but they were it
would come in like in a like in a paper
thing like the size of a comic book a
little bit and then it was wrapped in
plastic and then you bought it and it
folded out into like a big scene and
then it came with like these little
little figures that you get like rub on
there like with a you know like with the
back of a pencil or some people picture
frame I ordered oh yeah for your uh for
the thing for your thing poster yeah
okay so I wondered what that was
it's Dennis reads Dennis reads
he's in prison so weebles wobble but
they don't fall down that's that's some
of his old toys I had one called sucker
man remember sucker man so what sucker
like he was stupid or sucker like
octopus yeah they're kind of like The
Creature from the Black Lagoon had the
long tentacles for his arms and his legs
never suction cups all over it it looked
really cool in the in the box but that
you've rubber yeah but when you flipped
it over it was it was only like
two-dimensional it was all concave on
the other side what yeah real cheap I
thought it was gonna be like 3d well
yeah you wouldn't think that it was
shown in the commercials you could throw
it anywhere but stick like on the
ceilings but it didn't actually do that
of course how are you gonna get a stick
to a popcorn see worked on the damn
refrigerator in the glass I was like
don't throw that [ __ ] at the we're gonna
break the window you know sucker man
that one wasn't I can't believe that
that was what they decided to call it
what about what octo man was right there
sucker man or even squid man and then it
was it was because I was in this phase
where I bought this [ __ ] Stretch
Armstrong yeah remember that thing that
toy is a guy he's a bit arrested yeah we
were talking about that earlier cuz I I
had the one that looked like kind of
like the creature like there he's from
by the monster yeah that's the one I
wanted I wanted the one over yeah he was
cool yeah
I couldn't find it all right but I found
sucker man
so I got sucker masters that's like in
the package it look cool cool right yeah
like two dimensional you're like and
that's when you understood that
advertising lied yeah another one I
liked was I can t remember what it was
called though but it was like it can't
it was like a little monster it had like
it was big it was like this big and it
had like a monster head and then it's
middle part was clear and you could
there was like little stitches in the
front and you could pull it off and like
pull open his midsection and he had like
all these guts in there you could take
him out and then it came with like all
this gloop and you could put the gloop
in there and then stuff all the all his
little organs better than ever that I
don't remember what it's called but I
really liked that younger than me says
after my time I guess it might have been
yeah cuz I think it was actually my
brother got it and I was probably a
little too old but I thought it was cool
cuz I was a monster and also um the
play-doh like mad scientist thing yeah
they had like this a little mad
scientist lab mat and it had like came
with all these little molds where you
could make little Frankenstein's a
little mommy's in June yes he's like and
anything I mean even from as long ago as
I can remember like when I was a little
kid anytime you if you wanted to like
super make me happy with a toy it's like
just give me something that have like
vampires and [ __ ] on it I'd have been
like all over it I also got off into
these micronauts yeah that's my
remembers my brother had those yeah oh
he's a little time travelers than you
called time travel yeah had a bunch of
David a bunch of different colors and
then some of them were bigger than
others and one of them was like a
magnetic one he had arms and legs and he
came with a horse too you could combine
him into a damn Cyclops and that's like
I was sent or sent Aria and it was it
was it was jet black but this sort of
white one too they realized what I was
looking at the jet black one and the
white one if you took the head off
actually it the white one especially
right it was G remember the
yes cast in white or black and the black
when they changed his head to look a
little look a little bit more got Darth
Vader but that was a those are Japanese
toys that rebooted for the United States
well yeah yeah they were just kind of
like these are cool-looking and kids
will buy them yeah they're because
they're cool look and it dr to have
didn't have to have him but the thing is
is in japan there's a cartoon went along
yeah
and the the micronaut that was sold is
like andromeda i think is what the name
of the damn thing was that was actually
just GE done in different colors with a
different head well you know it's easy
all you do need to do the [ __ ] and then
have G here so yeah hey it's like a
cool-ass yeah so they released it as a
micro not yeah Reyes where I mentioned
Easy Bake Oven I had one of those
my involvement yeah mine was like I
think mine was like the old-timey stove
one that looked like ooh I think it was
Holly Hobbie um it's weirdly you can
make an apple pie in there that was
legit pretty good you know I mean like
you wouldn't think that was only like
this big like a little personal apple
pie the chocolate cake was decent but I
think the apple pie was the best one
yeah girls had that I remember girls
have that yeah I had one of those and
she talked about the creepy crawler like
the thing maker we had one of those we
had the little I don't remember what the
name of it was but it looked like a
little smelting plant kind of and you
would put like these wax disks or
crayons or whatever like in this metal
thing at the top that got super hot
because they didn't have safety
standards but and you could like melt it
and then pour it into a mold and you can
make little cars like it came with like
all these little wheels and axles so you
could make like all these little cars
and race them and stuff and you can make
them out of wax so you know we had that
too burned ourselves on it several times
we also had one of those things where
you could burn into wood yes I mean what
s.res Baird cars oh that's right yeah
force commander was the white one they
were magnetic yep they made a Jeep Jiji
version yeah exactly yeah yeah barren
cars that's his name was he's kind of
like a ripoff Darth Vader he was black
and he had kind of like a head kind of
like Darth Vader then the white one the
white one was gee yes that Japan jig was
green and yellow yeah
but it was that same because I remember
when we used to go to that comic book
store they have a big jig head or it was
like a coin bankers yeah and and and the
horse the horse was also part of the jig
program that was like I think they made
that lit in this in the jig series and
you know you and if you if you like you
should watch jig jig is actually pretty
good you can get it probably you could
probably get it burned pirated off of
[ __ ] off of ebay I got a lot of
[ __ ] Japanese stuff pirated off of
ebay cuz they won't release it here yeah
cuz the Japan has [ __ ] up copyright
laws butt cheek was gonna guy who same
guy who made Grand Iser and and Mazinger
Z and great mazinger and both get a robo
get a robo and get a robo GE that was my
favorite things oh yeah real good real
good theme song gonna guy was a he was
you know he wrote manga you know for
comic books and they later on made him
into cartoons but no gonna guy wrote
good [ __ ]
probably grand Iser be his best one yeah
but but yeah yeah OG but the horse was
also part of that series I think later
on they made that horse for jiggy kind
of combined with it it was like cyborg
yeah jig was a cyborg somebody asked me
if I ever had the tiffany taylor doll
who could switch from blonde to brunette
i did indeed have that doll i had
forgotten it was called tiffany taylor
was that the same one cuz her head like
her scalp turned around right yeah yeah
she had like black hair in the front of
them blonde hair didn't wasn't she the
same one that also tanned like she came
with stickers and you could put a
sticker on her that was like shaped like
something and then he lay her out in the
sun and her skin would tan but it would
leave like a white spot where the
sticker was I'm pretty sure that that
was the same one but yeah I remember her
head turned around I remember where I
got that from I didn't have like a [ __ ]
ton of Barbies my cousin had a bunch of
Barbies and sometimes she would bring
him over and we were play with him I
wasn't a big dull person
like I liked I liked some dolls but it
wasn't like my favorite thing usually
I'm mostly I like like creepy toys or
creative toys like I liked I had like a
little pottery wheel and little painting
sets and books and stuff like that
and jammer row grammar I don't remember
that one oh that sounds kind of familiar
though yeah I don't remember that one I
mean if you what um that showed the toys
that made us is on you what Netflix or
something yeah that's like yeah that's
like a really fun show like remembering
all the [ __ ] about it's just funny and
like they kind of like the he-man toys
every day and thinking of how basically
they just wanted to make it to it
they're just they just made the cartoon
because they want to sell the toys like
the cartoon was kind of like it after
yeah you guys have to see how toys that
made us go see that on on Netflix yeah
and go watch the he-man one that's
really one of the best episodes yeah
they're all good but it's like yeah I
think the he-man was probably those are
the toys that I you know I kind of came
up with actually even before that too
and that was the old school toy
development you know if I could just
creative guys together [ __ ] hanging
out trying to forget why are we how are
we gonna what are we gonna sell little
boys craziest [ __ ] ever and the they had
a whole [ __ ] plan and just they were
just kind of making it up as they were
going and bouncing it off one another
it's kind of funny these toy gangsters
really is what they are toy gangsters
slash nerds trying to find an in a way
to get boys to spend their parents money
to drive them [ __ ] crazy all that I
got the power all that was because
although boys realized that didn't have
any power their balls are but blossom
around so they need a plow little boy
psychology well they did like a whole
bunch of marketing research yes like
that to find out and that was the word
that kept coming up when they had a
piece-of-shit toy they had to sell it
was already molded and it was a damn
tiger that was this big and I said we're
gonna sell that and it was just like
[ __ ] Tiger how the hell we gonna make
it green and put a saddle on it put him
on it I gonna ride a tiger like that
that's how he met he-man was invented
because they had a [ __ ] tiger they
had to sell that was what my favorite
stories about that it is because I liked
their creativity and coming up with all
this is what we got
so yeah we got to figure out a way to
like make an heir and the one guys like
that's not the scale that is not the
scale that Tigers too big because we're
gonna have him rise everyone's like
scratching their heads I got no power
and then then they're trying to show it
to people and they're like well what's
this - why because is there uh any news
we got a comic book for oh you got a
comic book you're pulling that [ __ ] out
of their ass there's like yeah we got
excited there's going to be a television
series they made they pulled that all
out of their asses just on the spot that
there was going to be conflicts and and
and a TV show but it worked because then
they showed them the drawings of what
they were making yeah okay that'd make a
great TV show yeah well that's what I
mean it's like that's what was so funny
about it because they're just so [ __ ]
ballsy about going to all these like
investors and [ __ ] like they're going
hey we got this on the end they didn't
have no they just like quickly once the
guy said okay that sounds good they're
like now [ __ ] now we gotta get somebody
actually and then what killed it was
Shira that's what killed it because the
little girls wanted that too and as soon
as they had a little girl version the
boys and oh [ __ ] this is the universal
truth man the [ __ ] boys are sexist
little boys are sexist they don't until
they hit until they yeah but when
they're little boys and you know a lot
of people have said that's why that's
why the new Star Wars didn't work
because nobody was interested the little
boys weren't interested in the toys
because the toys were mostly female
oriented who's gonna [ __ ] him by what
little boy think about this I try to put
myself in the shoes of a little boy
today I go to a [ __ ] to a Toys R Us
and I see a action figure of Admiral
hold Oh with the damn purple hair and a
dress I would never buy that that's like
where's her god I kind of love her folks
are probably geared toward
completest collectors more than children
yeah but the thing is what made star
what made Star Wars so successful was
all those [ __ ] toys that those boys
bought yeah
you know without having a little boys on
board you weren't gonna [ __ ] selling
toys and if you weren't gonna selling
toys then you couldn't justify a billion
dollar movies yeah because it was he it
was just something to try merchandising
you know Jesus movie said I had Castle
Grayskull and put my hamster on that
track I was a little bit too old for
he-man I was already I think in high
school when he man came out yeah because
you're a couple years a year two or
three years rather than me but my
experience with he-man was my best
friend his little brother was [ __ ]
big into he-man and me and Steve used to
just laugh our ass Oh with this that
gooks goods he had he's wonder what
talking to his little Rebeck which I'm
too AM Paul yeah he called the rabbit
grandpa we started calling ten nine ten
right eight [ __ ] oh yeah he [ __ ]
loved he-man and we uh I was like I just
graduated from high school moved back
from Brazil and went back to Michigan
was hanging out with Steve before he
went out to college and if I can I spent
that whole [ __ ] summer with Steve and
[ __ ] [ __ ] I was living in in and he
had a little [ __ ] room down the
basement that he built that was his word
worried don't get high and [ __ ]
well yeah he gonna play bass Bunga hide
during high school [ __ ] we'd go in
there and we'd [ __ ] screw chicks and
[ __ ] in this because our hangout pad
smoking anyway I lived in there for like
a couple months before I got my own
place anyway uh just [ __ ] he man
tours her everywhere and me and Steve
and [ __ ] a look at what the
because everyone I'm not loaded out they
did weird [ __ ] like you pressed a button
and a whole top in a spin around we kind
of made fun of like yeah we made fun of
them because they were just so extreme
yeah but if we were gooks his age loved
them I mean they were ridiculously macho
yeah you look at that [ __ ] like from
command oh I'm flattered I was gonna say
that's the whole 80s late action movie
aesthetic we're like so over-the-top
macho so it turned around and became
home alright exactly well and you could
tell that the people that design it if
you like watch the toys that made us and
stuff like the people that designed the
characters and stuff that's kind of what
they were yeah I mean they were just
like going completely over-the-top and
having a good time with it weren't like
taking it super serious I've seen some
of these generation Z dudes do a movie
review is like on commando and predator
1 and I don't want to call them soy boys
but they're soya SH you know they're soy
and they're they totally misunderstand
the era like they would seek commando
and think that the whole thing was a
comedy or think predator 1 is a satire
or that or they think predator 1 is a
critique of toxic masculinity or some
weird [ __ ] like that no man that was the
[ __ ] era that was the time that was
[ __ ] was serious yeah they didn't think
they didn't think much bad that's that's
the way it well they were just like well
everything in the 80s was over-the-top
over to everything right everyone had
big hair big fat everything was like big
yes extravagant yeah and stare overdone
the thyroids was steroids and steroid
use was [ __ ] InStyle dudes that looked
like that were in style yeah like
everything yeah it was her this out but
it was it was not it was not some kind
of [ __ ] um what I'm saying it was not
some kind of political statement or
anything it was for real well yeah it
hasn't got to a thing because I think
like after the 90s everything like what
post irony yeah you know what I mean
worse
like everything was like ironic ironic
and that's what they thought it was
ironic which I can see why you would
think that because he didn't will grow
up during that time period you don't
have any context right because you know
if you were born after the 90s when
everything was like and what was was it
was tongue-in-cheek um delve you there
which it but it wasn't really and it's
not well some of it was but I don't
think and they were like yeah did you
see him he beat that dude up over that
little thing and then he threw that
other dude
yeah it's satire like no man back in the
80s you'd get your ass beat
dude would beat your [ __ ] ass and
eighties that's just what they did well
you got out of line you get you ask me
it's a reality and you know it's a
reality in certain neighborhoods that
that's just still going on but I guess
you could say they're coming up in the
[ __ ] middle class kind of suburbia or
something get out i mean i guess i guess
as beatings are out of style i don't
understand it I understand it I've seen
dudes at the club do [ __ ] and and get
away with it and I would be like he
didn't have to me I have a [ __ ] beat
his [ __ ] ass for doing that [ __ ] but
they they do it now yeah you know you
seen him yeah see that dude coming
actually I almost did beat that dudes
ass remember the one that came up and
he's [ __ ] with you and he starts
[ __ ] with me and I threw his ass
across the [ __ ] but dance floor yeah and
that girls cuz that was [ __ ]
beautiful it was it was very it was very
good it was graceful but I think as I
let him go you know yeah and you didn't
get in trouble being in trouble because
all the bouncers know us and yeah they
saw everything yeah they were like man
that guy deserved it yeah well like I
said we had a friend female friend who
had a guy that was [ __ ] with her and
she's just like socked him right in the
[ __ ] face
yeah just any guy kicked out somebody's
asking about the Aurora model kits from
the 60s and 70s I remember those fondly
I did not have any of those I really
wanted some like really badly they were
like all they had like a creature in the
Black Lagoon they had Frankenstein's
monster and all that kind of stuff like
I said that was totally totally up my
alley because anything to do with like
horror or witches or vampires or ghosts
or anything like
I totally wanted that [ __ ] I was
thinking about it the other day too
because a long time ago like I wrote a
blog post about some of my favorite toys
when I was growing up or like some of
the horror themed toys that I liked and
I had completely forgotten about this
[ __ ] game that I had but when I was
doing research about it I saw a picture
of it and it just like brought back all
these feelings and memories and
everything like that there was a game
and it was called well it had a couple
of different names I think when I had it
it was called which which like you know
which which is it but it was like a 3d
game like you constructed this little
haunted mansion like out of cardboard or
whatever and then all armed I don't
remember exactly how you played it I
think he just had to go through this
mansion and like not get whatever did
not get like eaten by witches I don't
know what the [ __ ] thing was but I
remember like all the all the playing
pieces were little mice they were a
little plastic mice that were different
colors I remember there was like a clock
in there that played into it somehow
that kind of wood like the one in the
haunted mansion at Disney and I think
that was like trapdoors and [ __ ] but um
I have to look that up again because
it's like I I remember really like in
that game and me and my brother playing
it all the time that game and [ __ ]
mystery mansion
I [ __ ] love mystery mansion one of
the games that I designed three sorrows
is kind of like a kind of like a
Suspiria esque version of mystery
mansion where you kind of like build a
little house like while you go okay
questions and comments and [ __ ] yeah so
you remember is the witch witch board
game it had another name too I think it
was just called haunted house or
something like that but the one the
version I had was called witch witch the
box looked the same but the name was
different all right
wacky walkers no I don't remember why I
remember those I remember they were the
like the little they looked like a
little squid or an octopus right but
they were just like that squishy plastic
they were sticky they're an inch and a
half tall and they want they were
wind-up robots oh oh no I remember those
okay I don't I was sorry I thought he
was talking about ball walkers all right
like mall walkers
but tell me put the pad down make
predictions I'll make predictions in a
bit the GI Joe hovercraft oh I remember
that hovercraft
I think it was probably about two feet
wide about three feet long I think
that's the same one I may have had that
maybe I had though I had the GI Joe one
of the GI Jeff sets I had it was a big
tower and it had a line and he could
slide down the tower and he had a and I
had a damn six wheeled vehicle he could
ride in and a damn Egyptian sarcophagus
that he could dig up oh yeah and then I
had a lot of the Vietnam era stuff where
he had a BA ours and and [ __ ]
green-green [ __ ] uniforms and
camouflage Special Forces uniforms and
[ __ ] yeah my brother had a bunch of the
GI Joes I remember I remember liking the
little figures who was the one that was
like he was like a little firefighter
like his little outfit was yellow and
red remember the medic was a metal GI
Joe they were like little metal diecast
metal soldiers but their skin was chrome
even though they had [ __ ] green
uniforms they were made out of solid
metal they were fully articulate they
were really cool I forgot what they were
called
yeah metal man maybe I think is what
they were called I really like those
yeah that sounds familiar
yeah which which alternate names ghost
castle haunted house new haunted house
yeah because I think the version I had
and I think I might have got it
secondhand because I could you know my
parents you know they would sometimes
like find some games like it you know
goodwill or whatever I had the one that
was called witch witch but when I was
looking at it online I saw one that was
called haunted house 2 but the Box
looked just the same and the game looks
just the same it was just like the name
that was different I'm not really sure
why they named it something else
metal man that's right metalman metalman
was real cool they made a lot of them
look like SWAT team guys some of them
look like Special Forces commandos they
were like sleeveless and they were in
their [ __ ] painted green uniforms you
notice give it and they was funny it's
like all the all the skin was chrome
like they were shiny chrome they've got
like a t1 that the [ __ ] that the
t1000 from the you know from there to
kind of like that it had clothes on
pretty cool yeah somebody says oh
there's a good modern haunted house game
called revenge
on the hill I've heard of that but it's
like and it looks really cool because
you know since I design my own game
since I designed my own games I kind of
you know research other games and stuff
like that and I've that looks like what
I really really want to play that one
and I found this other really cool when
it's super expensive though so I haven't
bought it yet called I think it's called
letters from Whitechapel or something
like that and it's kind of like where
you play a cop and you have to like try
to catch Jack the Ripper like before he
you know killed one of his victims and
that looks super cool although I was
reading through the rules I'm like wow
this looks really complicated I'd like
that your honor to play this but um yeah
like all this [ __ ] I used to really
like board games and I still like
designing them um but you know Tom
doesn't really I can't really get into
playing games with me you know so it
kind of sucks begins got it betrayal the
house a little yeah that's right
that was yeah that was one that I looked
at because it's kind of similar because
I'm working on a Halloween one like a
Halloween themed one but I'm also
working on another like giallo themed
game like another murder mystery type of
game and I'm kind of using some aspects
of betrayal on the house on the hill and
like a couple of other games and a
little bit of letters from Whitechapel
and a little bit of some other rules and
[ __ ] like that too
because you know it's that when I get
like to be certain like murder mystery
games I kind of like the I do thank you
very much
mango badger thank you very much umm I
get to a point where it's like I want to
do a murder mystery game and I like the
idea of you know like these party games
where that's this whole mystery like
everybody comes over and they have to
solve it but the only thing I don't like
about those type of games is that you
can only play them once like with one
particular group of people because once
the mystery is solved then everybody
knows with the solution of the mystery
is you can't play it again so I'm trying
to do like murder mystery games that are
like that but that are a different
murder every time kind of like clue
where you know you can change it up
every time so you don't get a thing
where you can't play it more than once
you know what I mean so it's kind of
hard to you know think of a way to do
that without it getting like really
complicated but
you know what's that's kind of what I'm
trying to do yeah there you are I feel
like I'm 2 pounds lighter that's why
clue rocks different ah have birthday
dude thank you very much happy birthday
actually
I'm not no thank you I can't wish you a
happy birthday it's not your birthday
we're drinking in the afternoon
yeah I guess they never did storm really
bad I heard all the thunder and I
thought it was gonna be like worse than
that yeah happy unbirthday that's when I
was thinking I used to have that
remember the the Disney Alice in
Wonderland that had that a very merry
unbirthday so I had that to anybody okay
here's another thing you remember from
childhood Disney used to put out like
every time they did an animated movie
they put out these big record albums
that had all the songs from the animated
movie and then it had like a book like a
little booklet inside the sleeve that
you could pull out and you could like
follow along so I had one I had an Alice
in Wonderland one I had the Aristocats
you know what I mean
you're going down record albums then
from childhood right yeah
and we tell you something let me give
you yes the Mad Hatter song exactly
I'm gonna tell you guys what my favorite
album was as a kid I would listen to it
over and over and [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
headphones on it was Thin Lizzy's War of
the Worlds album that was a double album
yeah of the War of the Worlds it was
narrated by Richard Burton and a whole
bunch of other people and you can hear
it on YouTube
and they've actually done a live
productions of it with the damn Martian
war machines and all kinds of [ __ ] yeah
we were watching on YouTube yeah but I
love that [ __ ] I think was a double
album yeah and I would listen to that
[ __ ] over and over again [ __ ] you
know war the world you know is [ __ ]
hilarious one of my favorite albums when
I was little because my dad is like a
huge beat
fan right so I got into the Beatles when
I was like really really young and I
know this if probably everyone's gonna
laugh about this but I saw that terrible
but also I still kind of love it the
sergeant pepper's Lonely Hearts Club
Band movie with the Bee Gees and Alice
Cooper and Aerosmith and stuff in it no
Alice Cooper wasn't it I don't think was
he I don't know Aerosmith was in it BG's
were in it Oracle says her husband has
that dam or the world's yeah see it's
cool right yeah it was made by Thin
Lizzy yeah or Timlin no Thin Lizzy yeah
then losing a head like I all-star cast
and Richard Burton worked it up did the
narration and it's Brock music and
pretty it's pretty cool it's almost like
a dam it's almost kind of like a Pink
Floyd album but it's got the entire
narrated story of the world of worlds
it's kind of like the Orson Welles radio
program kinda yeah but I thought it was
like the most fun rendition of that
story well it yeah it definitely is that
yeah but yeah so because I liked that
terrible sergeant pepper's Lonely Hearts
Club Band movie which I really I'm kind
of like afraid to watch it again because
I loved it so much as a kid and I'm sure
it's awful like if I watch it now but so
I really really liked the you know the
sergeant Pepper's album my dad had a
picture disc of it that had like the
cover of it like printed on the vinyl
and it was really really cool and the
funny thing is I used to listen to it
when I was a kid and when I was really
little I didn't know that when you had
headphones on this is gonna sound really
dumb but I didn't know that when you had
headphones on other people couldn't hear
the music so I would have the headphones
out of my dad's like my dad that's
really expensive like stereo system and
so I would play the album and I would
sing along to it with headphones on so
all they could hear was me say clucked
it because they could hear the music and
it's like I was really when I found out
that all they could hear was me singing
I was like super super embarrassed
because I was like really stupid yeah
I think the Jeff Wayne musical version
of them is that is basically the same
thing as that album I'm talking about
because I know I know they were doing
that album
live on stage also recently and they had
a whole show and everything that might
be the same thing yeah cuz when we were
watching it on YouTube what was that
must have been like a year or two ago
but I don't remember when it was posted
but I remember it was really it was more
recent yeah yeah and a Martian war
machine yeah they had all look like it
was right out of the dam yeah it was the
album cover like they did like a huge
production hmm all right
are you are you done or you want to talk
about some more stuff oh and uh more
stuff straight yet yeah me neither
maybe I should go peanut what'd you take
I still have like half a drink left yeah
and I don't know when you're when that
meats gonna be done either it's three
o'clock right I can give it another hour
it's only it's only a 180 degrees you
cook something forever at that
temperature doesn't make a big
difference what this done it's done well
it seemed smaller than flashbulbs let's
see what everybody's saying
tom has booze to convert a conversation
continues
so is that jet is Jeff is the Jeff Wayne
showed that same album that I'm talking
about is he's just doing that album okay
and Liam Neeson is nearing
what's up Stig's the porks probably to
be pulled pork probably put some
barbecue sauce on it make a sandwich out
of it okay it's the same album right all
right mmm all right so does anybody want
me to make predictions I predict that
the shit's gonna get more [ __ ] up than
it is now it's gonna continue to move in
this [ __ ] direction and man it's not
good it's not good and its global the
entire West whatever's happening here is
happening over there - that's what my
favorite beer is your favorite beer
I like vison beer man German fights and
beers white beers you need any of them
as long as it's good you know I like it
kind of heavy kind of sweet but I'm not
a huge beer fan know me it's a recipe
for getting [ __ ] fat I got a drink a
lot of that to get drunk and spend all
your time pissing and then you [ __ ]
fat man cuz a few times I mean cuz
there's a couple bars we go to around
here that don't have like a cute like a
full liquor license cuz they're very
expensive to get and really no um so you
go to like smaller places like the
Falcon or something like that so
basically they just kind of specialize
in beers yeah and um I tend to like they
like they had a vanilla Porter for a
while that I liked I liked coffee beers
I'm not like a big connoisseur I don't
like I was like I'll drink snakebite
yeah those
like especially like with the pear cider
yeah it's like half stout and half cider
yeah and when we're at that one place
there's pear cider but but the apple
cider is good you know and they're not
talking about its alcoholic cider you
know yeah it's like drinking them wine
and wine and beer together I guess I
didn't really it's funny because I
didn't really start drinking all that
much until I was much older probably
like in my late 20s or 30s like when I
was a teenager I didn't really drink all
that much so it kind of took me a while
and I guess when I started drinking I
didn't really just start on beer I just
kind of like went right to I just went
right to the hard stuff and yeah mostly
I just like vodka and gin to be honest
with you yeah yeah people that don't
want to be involved or gonna get
involved because it's be forced out just
like yesterday when that woman was
trying to just go down the street and
those people jumped in front of her
vehicle and that guy shot her they
caught that guy a few hours ago the god
got it right on video note there's
they're all dressed in black and Tifa
guys if somebody gets in front if I see
dudes dressed in black jump in front of
my [ __ ] car
I'm just gonna floor it I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm a floor it run I'll run him
right over because that woman just tried
to get the [ __ ] out of there and that
dude open fired on it and then shot
through her back window I'm considering
that if you jump in front of my vehicle
then this is an attempted carjacking I'm
just gonna run you over I ain't gonna
stop I'm gonna stop and the cops are
gonna have to [ __ ] kill me all right
that's that's that's what I'm at now if
I'm going kamikaze mentally inside you
they're just gonna have to kill me I'm
not standing for it it sucks cuz I got
Jenny and Pookie but they just gotta
have to [ __ ] kill him out you know
just it's it's okay alright it should be
alright I'm a hooker up with a check me
and Pookie be just fine
[Laughter]
what's Pookie been up to today sleeping
in the [ __ ] upper tank sleeping in
apartment she's [ __ ] hilarious man Oh
money money money unique okay still
working on the recipe book yeah it's
gonna do a while but I'm trying to go
like I'm gonna try and get it out before
the end of the year we have been working
on it's like it's it's kind of hard to
cuz like I said I'm kind of like at a
you know at a place where I could
probably start working on it but it's
kind of hard to get you and be
coordinated on you know cuz I wanted you
to like record yourself like talking
about the recipe is so I could just like
to describe them yeah I have a whole
list there's a couple things I'm going
to add to it probably on the southern
food section but I'll remember it when
the time comes I might throw some
breakfast and [ __ ] in there to the right
breakfast is breakfast breakfast is song
was gonna be kind of funny [ __ ] I think
maybe but well like I said there's like
there's tons of cookbooks so we have to
be it has to be funny I mean but you
want [ __ ] in there that people can
actually make that's actually good but
it has to be sitting on a plate I want
an Italian section in there because I
want to talk about pizza
yeah and how to make pizza dough and how
to actually deal with dough because I
think a lot of people are intimidated
with working with dough but it takes a
while take some trial and error but but
making dough isn't that making dough and
[ __ ] it up is not expensive yeah so
you don't lose much when you [ __ ] up a
dough you know yeah a few cents once you
can make your own dough you can make a
[ __ ] big ass pizza for under a dollar
yeah well and not only that you can make
like a bunch of differences yeah yeah
yeah you can make any kind of Italian
bread yeah where that cuz you know
gotcha yeah if you know how to deal with
dough you can take a few cents worth of
flour and a little bit of water a little
bit of [ __ ] yeast and make a lot of
food and that's how [ __ ] for
centuries that's how poor people got by
bread yeah and you know well its calorie
rich and now you know yeah and it
doesn't cost that much to me it's
delicious and if you think that you've
eaten [ __ ] a huge meal fit for a [ __ ]
King and alls it was a little bit tomato
sauce and some herbs and some
some vegetables on it yeah some cheese
yeah you've made a big one the nice
thing about making like pizza dough in
particular is that pizza is such a you
know it's such a verse at all I mean you
can put pretty much whatever you got
yeah on there I mean we've made ones
this ultimate poor people food we've
made ones with blue cheese on it we've
made ones with like cream cheese on them
delicious by the way yeah you don't need
tomato sauce if you don't want yeah you
don't even we've done ones which is like
Oh pesto we've done ones with just you
know like a kind of a olive oil yeah you
don't even really need cheese not really
you know it helps but just olive oil
herbs and maybe some meat that's you
know it's more like a focaccia yeah but
that's that's all that is yeah cheese
just pizza without tomato sauce and
cheese you know you can still eat it
it's good yeah any Brazilian style
breakfast option someone else
what are they located in Brazil during
the time I was there what they basically
eat is a piece of French bread with a
bunch of raw fruit and coffee that's in
in some way and it seems like that's a
very that's a pretty common European
thing to wear they just have like a roll
like a croissant or something like that
and fruit and calm yeah they're not
breakfast eaters really now they have a
thing with it the best thing that I
liked that was considered to be
breakfast by a Brazilian with something
called vitaminas and vitaminas is really
just what we would call today a smoothie
yeah and they take they would take
papaya and some other kind of fruit with
some fruit juice and some yogurt or
cream and blend it yeah so like a lot of
people do that yeah and that was really
the best thing the rest of it was just
fruit and coffee
yeah with a piece of bread and butter
which sometimes that's good I mean yeah
it gets boring
yeah um when it comes to breakfast
America has superior breakfast to the
entire world hashbrowns omelettes
[ __ ] bacon and eggs pancakes waffles
waffles
waffles with strawberry strawberry water
[ __ ] Eggs Benedict [ __ ] you know
steak and eggs ham and eggs you know
[ __ ] grits grits loaded grits [ __ ]
grits with red-eye gravy
it's just America the American breakfast
is a [ __ ] meal and you can eat it at
any time of the day actually I like
breakfast at night when I'm drunk I do
too
every cent like seriously whenever if I
wish downtown like not so much nowadays
but when we used to go out drinkin like
on Saturday nights because whenever I'm
drunk and we're out that's all I ever
want is eggs or I want like a big you
know like I want a [ __ ] Grand Slam
like from Denny's or something like that
um you know usually we would end up
stopping at McDonald's and just getting
like Egg McMuffins and [ __ ] or sausage
muffin which is superior to that I think
yeah in my opinion and get some hash
brown like iced coffee like I like it to
you but I like the sausage much better
it's just I like the I don't know I like
the ratio and the spices on it better
but um I always always always want
breakfast food like on our drunk that's
all we ever want and but the thing about
it is that I really love probably
breakfast food is probably one of my
favorite category if you know American
breakfast foods like I love pancakes I
love waffles I love eggs I love all that
kind of stuff but it's like a lot of
times I mean I wake up so early that my
stomach is just not ready to face that
much food like that early in the day so
usually if I eat anything for breakfast
I'm gonna have coffee obviously but
usually I'll have something very small
you should look a cup of yogurt with
fruit in it or you know a piece of toast
or something layer just like a
hard-boiled egg or something because I
can't like eat that much food I would
like I like having big breakfast but I
usually like it later in the day I've
gone through and seen foreigners
reactions to American breakfast you know
create the Korean reaction the Japanese
reaction the Chinese reaction European
reactions British people have the
closest thing to in a meal they have a
full angle it's it's very don't somebody
just mention that thing that I had that
if you say American breakfast is an
extension of the British bread yeah
really it's similar very very similar
and
they and everybody pretty much loves
America and [ __ ] breakfast because
there's so much to choose from that
[ __ ] country gravy that's good for on
biscuits on it on an omelet they call
that a southern omelet there's a lot of
[ __ ] you can do southern set of southern
[ __ ] white gravy or sausage gravy
that's good even with grits mm-hmm and
you see a lot of Europeans do not
understand do not understand the virtue
of a grits well you can't eat them plain
they do not know when the grit trees are
in season yes that's the American
polenta yeah it's hominy we can take
dried corn that you would feed to cattle
you take that and you put that in a big
bucket with a whole bunch of water and
lie and let it sit there to just blows
up into something call hominy you can
buy that canned and it's like wet
popcorn they don't know why it's popcorn
yeah but it's we always had cans of it
but its moist cabinet my grandmother's
know let's take that hominy and then you
blend that to make little grits yeah a
little bit you take that then you put
cheese in it sausage or bacon or [ __ ]
and diced red peppers and [ __ ] Cajun
seasoning in it salt and pepper and
butter and it's just fantastic I mean I
like our boiled eggs yeah man I'll I can
eat it just with a bunch of butter and
pepper in it um but it's much better if
you put like hard-boiled eggs and or you
know pieces of bacon or something here's
the upside to grits a 50-pound bag of
grits might be five dollars grit grit
trees are always in season good trees
are always well like I said it's really
funny that I mean I guess grits aren't
as um you know I guess a lot of people
[ __ ] on them before but now that polenta
is kind of like a bigger thing and it's
kind of like a gourmet kind of food I
think that stuff the American polenta
it's like polenta or like cream of wheat
I guess like a similar thing except it's
corn instead of yeah wheat
but you know you just have to know what
to do with them it's just like I said
it's a sense of I think people if you
eat it plain I agree it doesn't really
taste like much of anything it just
tastes like wallpaper face or something
like that if you don't do anything with
it but it's just it's a canvas you have
to like paint upon it and add other
things to it and then it's good you know
what I mean because like you know if you
get like for example I've been to
Denny's in a long time but if you go to
Denny's and you get like the Grand Slam
and if you get grits with it they just
give them to you plain and they really
don't taste very good you have to put
like a whole [ __ ] half stick of
butter in there to make them taste good
but it's Denny's what are you gonna do
you know I don't know I've never had
Waffle House grits oh you see mangle
he's gonna Tom a lovely man but the full
length is just uh yeah see we got jumped
on that didn't see the British breakfast
is the American breakfast is an
extension similar yes extension of it I
think the full English inspired that
yeah the American breakfast just we had
different components and then it had a
bunch of different ethnic traditions and
all that God put into because I think I
can't remember because I haven't like I
had a few full English as well I can't
remember exactly what every time you
know there's eggs and there's saw some
kind of sausage and usually tomatoes and
something else I can't remember what
else comes with it somebody somebody
from over there needs to like remind me
okay all right Jer saying that it's
tricky dealing with dough dough is the
only tricky when you don't have enough
[ __ ] flour in it okay if you slowly
add flour to that dough all right and it
starts off to be very gummy it sticks to
everything and then as you mix as you're
mixing and you slowly add the flour as
soon as the flour pulls away from the
bowl and becomes easy to deal with it's
a ball that now holds onto itself and
doesn't stick it doesn't stick to
anything else
you now know that you've that you've
basically absorbed all that water and
you now have something you can deal with
once it's like that you cover it in
olive oil and you let it sit let it sit
for a couple hours
it blows up you keep need needing it
back and a couple goes up again you need
it back down over I'll make sure I'll
write all of it down and you usually
want to let that sit at least 24 hours
in the refrigerator
it's dose better 24 24 hours it's all
controlled fermentation day two and day
three is even better yeah I mean if you
use it when you've just made it but it's
much better if you let it sit now day
four it starts getting a little
questionable five and six it starts to
break back apart you start smelling
alcohol it'll make a pizza dough it'll
make a really good pizza dough but it's
difficult to deal with it wants to break
apart instead of stretch so you got to
learn how to roll it right and you got
to know how to [ __ ] deal with the
surface so doesn't stick to it things
like flour and cornmeal you have to
understand how to use that but you get
the feel for it
and you have to realize to you that if
you're gonna make pizza dough
you have to like plan ahead yeah like a
dam too because what he'll do is he'll
be like well I'm making some sauce today
and we'll just have it on spaghetti but
then I'm also making dough and I'll let
that sit for a day or two and then we'll
use the rest of the sauce and make
pizzas yeah over the next four or five
days right now it will freeze yeah and
you make more dog jodan you're gonna use
I make enough for about six pizzas and
I'll make try to make six pizzas over a
three or four day period if not you can
freeze it yeah but you gotta let it thaw
out at room temperature before you use
it but I've gotten to the point where I
just use it all yeah I don't think we
start losing and you know for a long
time we just usually end up making
pizzas over several days you can freeze
it but a thawed frozen dough the the
consistency of that [ __ ] pizza crust
will not quite be as good as one that
has never been frozen yeah you want the
outer outer part of the crust to be
crisp but you also want to kind of
stretch and pull as you bite it off it's
kind of chewy at the same time it's a
chewy Center with kind of a crispy
outside
and you want kind of that beer flavor to
it which is a yeasty flavor yeah you
I'll write it down in the book I'm
getting kind of drunk man go badger says
[ __ ] I'm drunk sorry guy yeah and you
want us there's a couple rules when it
comes to [ __ ] Pete's one of them is
you want to stay away from all-purpose
flour you want heavy bread flour that's
the one you and here's another you
cannot don't make me mad cuz they make
me mad a lot
you cannot cook a pizza on metal they
try to cook this [ __ ] on a metal [ __ ]
pizza pan you cannot cook a pizza dough
on metal it has to be cooked on stone
yeah so you buy a thing called a pizza
stone because it cooks by induction the
[ __ ] stone has mass and it's hot when
you put that cold dough on it the heat
is sucked right out of that [ __ ]
stone and goes right into that dough
it's in the cooking times twelve minutes
okay twelve minutes it has to cook very
very high temperature very fast through
induction you're not gonna get that
through metal and pizza stones are not
horribly expensive I think the one I
think I gave you that one that we have
now I think that was $50 yeah it's worth
it though cos yeah thicker stick you
want to I mean I stopped or we had
bought one cuz we bought one at the
grocery store that for like 20 and I
think it was 20 or 25 in it right it
cracks eventually and we used it for a
while but then eventually so I bought
like a much thicker one that was so you
asked yourself
we still have how the [ __ ] do you get
cold dough onto a searing hot 500 degree
[ __ ] stove you must have a peel looks
like a appeal looks like a big old snow
shovel and you got to learn the
techniques of getting a pizza on to that
thing and off of that thing you know cuz
pizza dough tends to want to stick you
got to use cornmeal yeah
and you can't leave it cuz another thing
that you stay long well and it depends
on what kind of pizza you're making too
because we've run into problems with
this too the more [ __ ] that you put on
the behavior it is the heavier it is so
what
like if we may like dick like like a
chicken pizza or something like that
like with chunks of chicken on it
because we make that sometimes what
we'll do is like we'll just put like the
light [ __ ] on the pizza put it in the
oven then close the door and then pull
it back out and throw the chicken on
there room way back in because if you
try to have everything on the pilot day
to go when I go on a field and you start
with small pizzas first until you work
your way up to the confidence you've got
to take the peel and put it on the stone
you got to fibrate your hands back and
forth like that and slide it off shake
it off pull it out maneet there it's you
practice on your island or outside
surface of getting a [ __ ] pizza dough
on and off a damp peel yeah and then you
put sauce on it's a little bit of cheese
and make it and do the same thing with
cheese pizza over and over again you go
I can do that then put a little bit of
[ __ ] pepperoni that's way much
you'll do it again yeah I can get it off
and on there then you didn't in the last
time you put it up in there and then do
the same thing on the stone yeah but if
it's a [ __ ] really thick pizza with
like six toppings on it yeah cuz we
you're not gonna be able to do it if
it's just like one that has like you
know because we did want to like with
pepperoni or just like you know peppers
or something like that but if you start
getting into because we've made one
we've like chunks of chicken like
artichoke hearts [ __ ] like that on there
once you get it is kind of big kind of
little masses yeah kind of things you
probably want to wait until it's all
ready and put it in as a cheese pizza
cook it for a few minutes and then pull
it back out top it again because it's a
lot on the rack out depends on what it
depends yeah it might be for an for some
people to just take the pizza back off
the stone leave it on the peel top it
again and then sling it back in there
yeah you could probably do this because
at that point like the dough is probably
like firmed up
yes firmed up on at the bottom so it
slides a lot easier yeah I mean you know
he's been doing this for years and years
she's got like and pizza is probably
like what's one of the hardest ones what
and it's one of your signature thing
yeah it's like whenever we have you know
parties whenever we have a bunch of
people over we either make pizzas or we
make Indian food because it's easy to
make like a [ __ ] ton of that
like at the same time Indian food is
good because you can make a bunch of
that ahead of time in like the second or
third day it's like even better than the
first they're saying Indian breakfast
food is having especially South Indian
you have to give me more more
information I don't really know what
dishes they are a lot of times Indian
food what I've been seeing for breakfast
is just kind of like bread bread and
vegetables and be like like a vegetable
curry is it's not breakfast tea from
what I remember seeing although I may be
wrong well it's funny for me that is for
breakfast for Americans and British is
centered around eggs yeah basically some
kind of an egg egg with something else
you know either bacon or ham or or just
toast I just like I just like a couple
fried a bruised toast then you take the
egg and turn the egg into our almond
with cheese and some sauces you know so
it's variations of egg either that or we
like really sweet things like I said
like pancakes or waffles or doughnuts or
something like that which probably I
don't know I wonder why like doughnuts
became like kind of a breakfast thing
because that seems like it would be more
of a dessert thing you know what I mean
it's seen cuz it's like cake more than
breakfast yeah I ain't no doughnuts had
anything dude breakfast muffins yeah
well it seems like doughnuts are kind of
like that's you know [ __ ] Dunkin
Donuts their whole model was like people
coming through their breakfast time and
getting coffee and a doughnut and that
was like breakfast time but like I said
I just you know I would eat doughnuts
for breakfast too in fact one of the
most exciting things for me about
staying in hotels it's just you I don't
stand tells that often but I like to
stay in hotels with like those [ __ ]
big ol breakfast buffets that are free
and they just felt like everything they
have a grit station and a waffle iron
and like [ __ ] all different kinds of
cereal and there's big long things I'm
like super excited about that big piles
of donuts and bagels Oracle sandy she's
make pizza yeah this week yeah if you
have you know if you don't know how to
make it there's tutorials on how to make
it but it's an investment to get into
the pizza game but once you know if you
want to make it really really good once
you once once you've laid out the money
to get the stuff you need to make it
it's it pays dividends because you don't
have to
go to a pizzeria anymore to have pizza
he can just make it yeah because I mean
the pizza you make is like way better
yeah I'd only cost a couple dollars each
one yeah it doesn't now that we've
already got the stuff we got the stone
we got the peel we got all that kind of
[ __ ] I mean it takes some time it takes
time to make the dough like I said you
have to plan ahead you make sauce from
scratch so that takes a while because
usually you make it out of a damn number
ten can [ __ ] tomato paste yeah it's
made a paste tomato sauce yeah that's
one you get it Sam's a can and he just
like makes a huge yeah make a bunch of
it part of it and then like you can do
other things with it like you said you
can just if you don't feel like making a
P today you can just like cook up some
spaghetti and coming out of a restaurant
background I don't think in terms of
small portions it's a waste of time I
think in terms of like large amounts
it's a lot more economical I mean I can
get what is a big ol two gallon jar of
[ __ ] pickles for the same prices a
little bitty [ __ ] a little bitty jar
of pickles why not get the big to Gala
pickles I'll just need a bowl I know how
I know how to store things long-term and
have a lot of containers and well we
have to refer to fridges we have one out
in the that's that we keep [ __ ] in so
you know and we go to Sam's like
probably once a month and just stock up
on [ __ ] tons of [ __ ] yeah we have
more food in this house than we will
ever be able to eat and we have like the
pantry and that's [ __ ] awful so but
yeah it's a well that's the thing it's
like you're really good at like figuring
out something to make and then you know
we'll eat off it for a couple of days
like leftovers and then if there's
anything left you just stick it in the
freezer we can eat it later and then
we'll just like make something else
speaking of which we really need to get
on we have like all the shrimp we gotta
use yeah I think that curry and I am I
love [ __ ] see dude and it's like we
were talking about we were watching the
[ __ ] Gordon Ramsay uncharted the one
that was on Sunday night where he was in
where the [ __ ] was he Sumatra or shrimp
masala yeah he was like he was making
some kind of like I don't remember what
he was making on that show but it was
like it looked really [ __ ] good like
with all these betas it's [ __ ] shrimp
that were like
most lobster size and they have like
these big long like blue claws like they
caught him in a cave or something and he
was like making some kind of delicious
looking curry with that like was coconut
milk and everything you make a really
good Thai curry - that has like peanut
butter in it he's saying is it really
mean only a couple bucks for a piece of
my exaggerating okay well let's break
this down just break it and on what
you're gonna put on it that ends on what
you're gonna put on it it depends on how
much you laid out for the initial
investment terms of like are you coming
out of a 20 pound or a 50 pound bag of
flour okay I think I'm using 20 pound
bags I think it's a 20 pound and a 20
pound bag of flour is only a couple
dollars how much was it exactly though
$70 $6 someone oh okay I don't like that
and then we got a themes right yeah yeah
and then like two pounds of two pounds
of yeast is about three dollars
something like that now last year yeah
each one each big batch of each each big
bowl that I make they can make six
pizzas is only six cups of flour 3
tablespoons of salt 3 tablespoons of
sugar 3 tablespoons of yeast so they are
yeah less than a dollar and that makes 6
pizza crusts now one thing that might
set you back is the mozzarella it's real
if you're getting the really good like
the buffalo mozzarella that is probably
gonna be your biggest expense because
even the little cakes of it like if you
go to Sam's I think you get two cakes of
it that are is that like $7 $8 yes for
to like bring it down so so six crusts
are less than $1 yeah for 6 crust so the
crust itself it's not there's no money
there really when you break it down
percocet a number-10 can of tomato sauce
it's unseasoned it doesn't have any
sugar
in it and doesn't have any season in it
but just that big number 10 can which is
about a month worth of tomato sauce I
think it's three dollars yeah it's cheap
yeah okay
the seasoning once you make that number
10 can the amount of seasoning and salt
and peppers in there is probably bought
a dollar two dollars and that number ten
can we'll make a [ __ ] ton of pizzas and
a whole bunch of to a whole bunch of
bowls of spaghetti Thank You Pico thank
you so next is cheese you can get a big
old thing a mozzarella for about ten
bucks that's like the part-skim
mozzarella part-skim mozzarella and
that's what you'd get at a pizzeria
anyway and you can get that from sam's
for about ten bucks
how many pounds is that I thought I
think that's a three three pounds or
five pounds I can't remember that
probably makes about eight pizzas yeah
that makes a lot of people more get more
than 80 like I said if you want the
buffalo mozzarella which is actually
better that's gonna run you more because
you don't get as much you just get like
the two cakes for like seven or eight
dollars now that big package of that big
package of pre sliced pepperoni that's a
month's worth of pepper on it's about
$80 $89 and you can make I'm gonna make
a bunch of pieces with that so just
pepperoni pizzas I'm saying you cost for
a single pepperoni pizza it's probably
about three dollars it sound about right
probably yeah maybe four but it's like
it's it's not really I think it's like I
said its heparin II Pizza knows about
three yeah I mean each component like if
you buy it in bulk you can make a lot of
Pizza make a lot of it right and
honestly it's like I I like pepperoni
but it's not my favorite topping plus it
gives me really bad heartburn yeah so I
mean I like pizzas with just like with
just mushrooms or mushrooms and peppers
and it's Sam's you can get a big thing
of uncut fresh mushrooms I think from
about $3 and yeah mushrooms are super
yeah
and I love much yes there's all the
different kinds of like red and green
peppers that you can get it's not a
couple bucks all that [ __ ] is cheap yeah
a two topping pizzas about two bucks
yeah
and we're talking about a pizza that's
the size of your pizza peel because if
it you can't put one bigger than your
peel on it so you're talking about a 12
a 13 inch pizza not two bucks I would
say yeah but you got to lay out more you
gotta lay out more money at once to get
these components of course because it's
bigger yeah but once you break it down I
would say around $2 like I said once yes
it's it's kind of like anything else
once you like spend all the money up
front leg yes you have to buy a pizza
stone yes you have to buy a Pelias you
have to buy this done the other you have
to buy like powder flour but after you
do that you can and like I said we did
have like a $20 pizza stone and we had
that for a while but then we had then it
cracked and then so I specifically got
one that was like much much thicker like
a ceramic one that was $50 Thank You
Niko let me see them flashbulbs bro
Minka bear says I've been listening you
guys while working safely from home but
it's not my lunch time and I have to go
hope you have an amazing birthday Tom
thank you dang it a love from Mott salon
Mexico there you go thank you mica bear
we have to eat more cake later
yeah I would love to go to Mexico I love
it I'd love to go to Mexico City and
some of the other places I like South
America I haven't been to Central
America though but at Brazil Uruguay
Paraguay Chile Argentina I've been to
those places and I really love South
America growing up there Mexico of
course you know when I was actually born
in Long Beach California and you know I
grew up with a lot of Mexican American
kids it's in the army with a bunch of
Mexican Americans and Southern
California was kind of like northern
Mexico it is yeah we had a lot of the
[ __ ] Mexican food and Mexican
restaurants there you know owned by
Mexican owners that you know would cook
real [ __ ] you know I grew up with a lot
of that and in those days this is the
70s you know Tijuana wasn't [ __ ] but
caught of aztlán he's from Tijuana and
he showed me pictures what's going on
going on down there until want us to
change a lot it's grown a lot that was
they used to be just a little bitty
border town yeah I remember recognize
yeah but it's got a lot of nice stuff on
it nice restaurants and if you know
where to go you know it kind of reminds
me a lot of the way Brazil was back in
the 80s yeah yeah I was thinking about
that the other day because I was reading
an article about how Mexican food had
kind of almost at this stage it's almost
become like American food just because
it's so ubiquitous well it's almost
everywhere you go to Korea and get
Mexican food well the weird thing about
it is that when when I was ground me and
you grew up in Southern California so
it's like you know you guys had Mexican
food like all the time but I feel like
until maybe the 80s or 90s where I grew
up those foreign foods it was yeah it's
like we had Taco Bell but that's like
not really that's just kind of like a
weird simulacrum of like Mexican food
that's been a corporate version of Cow
mix although there's something about I'm
not a big fan of Taco Bell but I know
it's good I know that a lot of people
like talking but nobody thinks it's like
actual real Mexican food or anything but
sometimes that's kind of what you want
it's kind of like we were talking about
this the other day it's like you know as
much as like we like to cook everything
at home and like everything tastes
better sometimes it's just every now and
then it's just you know what I just want
a [ __ ] quarter pounder man you know
they hated some McDonald's fries it's
like it's not good it's not good for you
or anything like that but for some
reason sometimes you just want that well
you know and like I said sometimes we
[ __ ] just give it absolutely [ __ ] it
man we're just we're going to Captain
D's and getting some [ __ ] deep fried
fish and hush puppies yeah some fried
green tomatoes not like I said not not
good not good for you but every now and
then that's just what you want you know
what are you gonna do
I had this youtuber he was it goes all
around the world
tasting street food and he goes to
Mexico and Mexico it goes to Tijuana and
[ __ ] Mexico City and he went to
another place down there and was eating
the demand of street food look really
good
that's what I mean it's like we've been
watching like Gordon Ramsay cuz like I
said he's doing that uncharted show it's
like every [ __ ] thing they make on
their Oh delicious yeah year yeah
carnival on Israel name is sucking gyre
[ __ ] we talk a lot off off site [ __ ]
but J or man want to tell you that
tortilla press you can get them here the
United States cast-iron ones just like
you guys used they're only 20 bucks each
so imma order 100 only 20 bucks no free
delivery
it's that same [ __ ] scoffs tired
[ __ ] press it looks cast-iron it
might be aluminum but it looked
cast-iron yeah yeah but they all look
about the same we would use that a lot
because we make I gotta hide stuff I
just need one yeah I mean we make um
what do you think I mean I was I was
trying to think the other day I think we
probably most commonly maybe not so much
recently but most commonly we make
Indian food yeah but I think second
after that is probably Mexican food yeah
we are always making burritos and if you
guys have had corn tortillas out of the
package they're pretty good yeah but I
got some of that damn meal what's it
called my second mother
yeah I got my second awesome and I made
some tried to make it to a couple couple
tortillas by hand it's actually a lot
easier if you have the press the flavor
was [ __ ] far superior they were
really good made their whole house yeah
whole house smells good you get that
Maseca
and and make your own tortillas with
that [ __ ] press you guys don't know
what you're missing [ __ ] man the flavor
is like four times yeah and the texture
is a lot better yeah I really I liked
them all yeah actually I mean the ones
in the package are fine but it's like
what once you have like the homemade
[ __ ] it's just kind of like I don't mind
like when we make Indian food I don't
mind just like buying the big thing is
like you know pre-made naan bread but
we've made our own naan bread yeah a few
times and it is actually much better
yeah I hey I think I have the Maseca
yellow bread yeah they sell that here
it's like we get I think it was yellow
- yo or yo
white I'm pretty sure he goes yellow
yeah got it Publix it's here yeah and
it's not expensive
yeah we're just like a couple about yeah
but I heard that in Germany that shit's
[ __ ] expensive there was either a
German or a British person saying that
they had it there I think it was a
German girl so that they had my second
that she was [ __ ] expensive well I
guess just the import yeah I guess it's
like saying that was one thing and I'm
not sure about the UK nowadays cuz I've
been there in a while but that was one
thing that I actually missed I was over
there was like they didn't have a lot of
Mexican food yeah you know what I mean
they brought they might now adays I'm
not sure because that was a long time
ago I think the last time I was there
was probably 2000 any idea on the price
of the cookbook oh gosh that it's gonna
depend on I'm kind of like from what I
estimated I'm assuming it's gonna be
like 35 but I'm not real sure because I
want to do a hardback yeah I don't want
to do paperback yeah it's not going to
be that cheap but it'll depend on the
page count I'm looking at like a 200
page book cuz that's about what that and
it's not I really beyond us these are
robot printing companies and it's all
just gonna set price piece I'm probably
gonna do it through Lulu because they
will actually do because I mean when I
you know do my books I usually do it
through what used to be called create
space
I think it's called KDP now but they
only have paperback options and I for a
cookbook I really wanted it to be a
hardback yeah we don't really control
the price they do well they well like I
said it has to do with Hessian there's a
page count right yeah it has to do with
whether you want like if you want full
color inside which we do yeah a
photograph if you want full bleed on all
the pages which we do cuz it just looks
better um you know whether like the
different kind of like coatings you want
on the cover and everything but when I
went through there cuz I did like a
price estimation like with a 200 page
book and it looked like our cost so it
looked like we would probably have to
sell it for like 35 it's not that bad
though that's what well yeah for like a
big hardback yes but like I said we'll
see how it goes it's you know we're
gonna try and get this thing done and I
want it to be super cool looking and
super like I said the one that I did
for the vegan black metal chef and I'm
like really proud of how that one came
out yeah and I want one that says Co I
don't want it to look like that one
because that's like his yes aesthetic
but it can of aztlán its gonna get some
credit in this book because he's pushed
me the right direction in the Mexican
section so he's gonna be maybe you've
been talking to him a lot about
different like about what's what should
go in there and what can be executed
outside of Mexico because some of the
people that are by this book are gonna
be in Europe so I'll make sure that they
can get these components talking about
tacos for you um
PJ waiters out there you Gringo's
[Laughter]
sometimes you know you have a problem
doing a real authentic Mexican fillings
it's very easy to make pico de gallo or
pico de gallo type salsa which is a lot
better than a store-bought salsa but
Jenny and I have found that for a quick
[ __ ] filling just a regular old damn
[ __ ] hot high-quality Gordon's fish
sticks we just like yeah and in amis
second if we feel like you know yeah in
a in a in a homemade talk a corn
tortilla shell that would be [ __ ]
awesome I saw I don't like I love
[ __ ] fish I gotta get that Presley
like I said if it swims in the ocean I
will probably in it yeah yeah I mean
because they eat them with fish a lot of
fish and [ __ ] shrimp and stuff in Mex
I love fish it's not it doesn't have to
be pork or beef that a lot of fish and
shrimp from what I saw on the street
food episode of what they were making
out there what member that taco place we
used to go to after I bar sometimes I
don't even know if it's there anymore
but that that one that was just like a
few doors down a lot of they would be
like a big line like after the bars
closed everybody go get tacos and they
had their fish tacos were actually
really really good big chunks of like
white fish in there yeah yeah I was oh
yeah and I'm gonna put a gumbo in there
yeah I'll put gumbo probably put a - a
fait in there yeah and maybe jambalaya
just you know the basics gumbo itself a
jumble
maybe a pistol a pistol a I don't if he
knows that pistol a is need a little
pistol you know it's a little French
bread it's been hollowed out that has
like a creamy shrimp filling in it so
you've never made that pistol or good
I've heard of it but I didn't know again
it's creamy pink pinkish red creamy
shrimp spicy shrimp filling see now in a
French braid yeah yeah it's outside of
its kind of buttered and toasted so it's
kind of like a bread butter and yeah yes
my three favorite things fried kind of
like a fried grilled cheese sandwich but
with shrimp yeah you're killing me over
here killin me look at that and we just
ate not too long ago well cuz I was
thinking like I said we were watching
Gordon and [ __ ] in Sumatra last night
on the DVR and he was making some like
really good [ __ ] with like some shrimp
and coconut cheddar you have a good yeah
I know it's like holy crap we've been on
we've been on almost two hours and I was
like worried because I was just gonna
like well we should do a livestream
because it's your birthday and it's like
I didn't even plan anything to talk
about it we watch the movies or nothing
yeah cuz you know what I did I was gonna
watch a new movie last night but then I
got all distracted by watching Gordon
and then he was like oh I need to go
take a shower so find something else to
watch so then I was watching Gordon
again like 24 hours to hell him back on
[ __ ] to be and then I noticed that
Netflix just added season 3 of dark and
I was like [ __ ] now I'm gonna have to
because I want to see that but I don't
remember what happened in the flick I
don't remember everything that happened
cuz it's a very complex story so I
started watching the whole thing over
again from season 1 yeah so expert so I
watched like the first three episodes
it's like the first season so I could
get all cut up so nobody so if anybody's
like started watching dark season 3 do
not spoil it for me because I'm watching
the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] over again before
I go and get into season 3 because I
totally forgot I didn't forget what
happened exactly but I forgot like all
of the relationships and everything
and I didn't when I wanted to like catch
up with it it's been like a year or two
since I've watched it but yeah so if
anybody if anybody has not seen on
Netflix the German series dark
you should totally especially if you
like like stranger things or any like
weird kind of sci-fi or anything like
that it's like really really cool
what mangoes saying stay away from fish
shakes is fish dicks is there's cheese
involved no not with now we're on taco
well yeah a lot of kind of like oh fish
and cheese don't go together and I'm
just kind of like depends on a taco it
does I mean I like that yeah I mean fish
tacos are common both in the United
States and in Mexico and they have
cheese on them and then but you also
have a you know it's also a corn
tortilla and it's got [ __ ] Pico which
is you know diced tomatoes onions maybe
like red pepper with like a kind of like
a vinaigrette or lemon juice and olive
oil type deal with with a little bit of
spice in it it works it works well very
well I have to tell you to that one and
I know like people are just probably
gonna go to and like you know judge me
and stuff but whatever we used to go to
the you know the all-you-can-eat Chinese
buffet who I want or whatever every now
and then they'd have this dish and it
was always like at the end like way over
in the corner Loyola so here were
ashamed innit way I forgot to tell you
mango Mexico does not use cheddar cheese
okay yeah the most common cheese are
used as mozzarella which I actually like
it's mozzarella better on Mexicans so
cheddar is good too but shadow can work
I like my Strela better they're using
white cheese occasional fresco which is
kind of like a white cheese yeah I don't
really like kids or fresco that much
it's a little salty and it doesn't melt
very well it's not creamy I think it's
good for maybe certain applications
maybe it's better in Mexico but the case
of frescoes that we have here castle
queso fresco the ones that we have here
there it doesn't melt very well it's
kind of waxy
I don't know a con dis just Mexican dis
queso fresco and Mexico does it melt or
is it kind of waxy yeah but there's one
thing that they make at the Chinese
buffet I don't even know what the [ __ ]
it is I don't know it's not Chinese I
don't think but it's just they make like
this it's almost like a casserole or
something but it comes out of this big
pan and it's like the the imitation
crabmeat like big chunks of like
imitation crab crab with a K and then
it's got some kind of it might be
cheddar cheese it might be I don't know
what kind of cheese it is but it's some
kind of like you know deeply yellow
cheese and they just kind of like melt
that over the top and then I guess they
bake it and there's some other [ __ ] in
there too but I don't know what it is
it's just like it almost looks like
mayonnaise I don't think it is but for
some reason every time I see that I have
like a little squeeze of joy because
it's like I'm sure everyone is
completely grossed out but I I really
really like that stuff even though it's
like just fish and cheese and it's just
like [ __ ] baked and a lot of people
are grossed out by imitation crab but
the thing about it is that even though
it's called imitation crab it's not like
fake it's fish is what it is it's not
like it's just fish that kind of tastes
like crab or they put like a little bit
of dye on it so it looks like a crab so
it's not like they just made it in a lab
or anything it is actually from an
animal they're just calling it an animal
that it's not yeah junior says that yeah
queso fresco does not melt very well
they're using how you say that Oh Aqsa I
don't know it's Oh ay ay ay OH ay X ACA
and I don't know how X is pronounced I
can't remember actually I think I looked
at that badge at one time but I don't in
Portuguese that would be X is pronounced
CH to be wash Oh Asha but I don't know
how if that's pronounced that way in
Mexican Spanish it might be similar okay
Kalka spark is in washa cajeta and
cha-cha whaa
I don't know what you want Chihuahua
yeah and in much a go so it's all the
different Mexican cheeses yeah outside
of Mexico most authentic for you as a
peach a waiter okay
the white boy okay it's gonna be
probably something like mozzarella yeah
that does seem to be because it's white
it's mild and it melts yeah okay you
could probably get it what would be good
with [ __ ] fish sticks in the United
States probably would probably be
something as crazy as Philadelphia Cream
Cheese would probably very good I would
eat the [ __ ] I need that
yeah I'd eat pretty much anything with
Philly cream cheese on it cream cheese
is I wish there Fatman was everything
but they got all kinds of fancy Mexican
cheeses that we don't have as it's
Oaxaca Oaxaca okay that's not a Hakka
all right yes he says fake crab not fake
food exactly right well it's just fish
they're just called you're not gonna be
able to get hoo-ha cup probably in an in
an average American Mexican either that
well you can look because I do like
grocery stores have actually come a long
way like particularly with their delis
and all that stuff because they I mean
Publix a winn-dixie and stuff like that
have a pretty big cheese section and
they have like cheeses from we have a
little bit more so I haven't looked for
it so they might very well know they
have like tons of like European cheese's
and stuff like that so we have lots of
Mexicans lots of Cubans well I would be
in Florida there's a lot of Mexicans and
Cubans in Florida I would sink more so
Cubans yes I've been here longer there's
a lot of you but it's very difficult to
tell a Cuban from a [ __ ] American
Irish there but they've been here for so
long they're so integrated into American
society Cubans in Florida are not forum
there's nothing about them foreign no
they're just another American but Oaxaca
I gotta look for that that's another
thing Mexicans that Mexicans shot that
Mexican store the little grocery store
the one that you get one that I ride I
go for it all right after you kitaro
kitaro hot sauce yeah I love that [ __ ]
well because they have some of the Lu
kitano in the regular show but they
don't have like the super super hot like
that they don't have a brown one and
brown
one you have to go to the yeah the
Mexican that's just so hot you can
barely eat it and they toned it down
yeah when I first got it for us was
hotter than it is I guess it was people
complained there's just man [ __ ] hot
but I liked it the way a little I'll
show you guys now how far is that that
you ride up there yeah every now and
then if he feels like going for a
motorcycle ride home right I have to
used to this look up all the way up
there just to like buy this one little
bottle of hot sauce it's like I said
they have the brand they have that brand
in regular grocery stores but they don't
usually have like the Azteca like the
brown sauce that's like the superhot one
I don't know why because everybody's
really sure everybody is like super into
hot sauce nowadays you would think that
this hottest loves hot sauce this is the
hottest one I can't eat just a little
bit it's backwards yeah that's how
cameras work I thought it would be the
same it's all don't go Larry
all right I can't [ __ ] pronounce that
it's I can't see them k UT b IL - i k de
kuta bill how do you [ __ ] say that
could - big Gala Lichty that sounds like
scary [ __ ] like you're about to cut my
heart out or something see that k UT b
IL britney Irwin says cream cheese is
good on most things
indeed it is alright that [ __ ] was hot
it's hot now but it used to be even
hotter back in the day then there was
this one is green one yeah alright and
then it came out with just seconds this
[ __ ] luxurious [ __ ] it's mild
though that tastes good but this one
right here man it contributed
[Laughter]
yeah they see that that's just famous
there in Mexico yeah they're all
habanero it all says habanero yeah the
green one tastes a little bit more like
like something based in more like
jalapeno it's like it's kind of like
kind of like habanero in jalapeno
together and then this one the black one
else is a habanero but it says black
label reserved black super fancy [ __ ]
but they're not hot
this one is [ __ ] hot that one really
I can't eat anything much hotter than
like the habanero yeah one like after
that like my you know yeah I just can't
eat things anymore it's up there making
everybody hungry and can we talk a
little bit too cuz we we're gonna put I
think in the aren't we gonna put in the
cookbook of Cuban sandwich yeah I was
gonna put some Cuban four of Cuban food
in it yeah because I lived in Tampa and
there's like a huge you like Cuban
community over there and it's like you
could get a good Cuban sandwich like
pretty much anywhere and there so I got
a look into what kind of meat exactly it
is that they're using it's some kind of
pork yeah some kind of pork yeah I'm
thinking that a Cuban sandwich could
also be executed in Mexico so I think
they could probably get all that
sandwiches are good right what kind of
bread it's a French bread so well they
call it cubed bread it's sort of like
french bread it's similar yes Emily it's
like a sub sandwich with the marinated
pork yeah and what else is in there [ __ ]
on you know I can't our look it's good
yeah it's good they're really good I'm
all the time it's a florida's version of
like a hot sub sub sandwich yeah yeah
I'll probably put some down Florida
drinks in there probably puts them like
what's the [ __ ] rum drink that's that
man used to drink here all the time
[ __ ] drunk I can't think of the rum
drink - rum drink with the [ __ ] mint
in it oh yeah your monkey - mojito yeah
it's a rum drink with kind of like lime
and mint even though I think it's Puerto
Rican in origin and it originally wasn't
meant there was some other herb that
they had this like mint then everything
is better with me but here in Florida
they make it with mint
yeah and it's a good hot weather rum
drink it's very refreshing very
refreshing on ice and in a big [ __ ]
jar and yes jar is a [ __ ] damn this
is class high-class [ __ ] and mojitos are
drunk out of this [ __ ] pickle jar and
we fill a [ __ ] ice and it's light
green it's got the dab crushed crushed
fresh mint in it it's just it's like
having an iced tea get out I mean it's a
refreshing summer drink but and they're
not strong really there's not a lot of
alcohol at him you can drink a lot of
him
yeah well it's one of those where you
can just you drink them all day yeah
where it's kind of like where people you
know do like Bloody Marys or or do like
a mimosa or something like that where
you can drink them during the day and
they don't you know they don't drink two
or three of them yeah they're easy to
control but they're nice and cool and
refreshing and you drink it over a
period of you know repeat a few hours
you don't mean watching movies and
they're nice yeah it's a South American
thing and a [ __ ] Mediterranean thing
you got time there's no sense it's not
like it is in Europe we're trying to get
drunk fast see I get back to work the
next day it's not like an tropical
region you know in the warm weather you
take all [ __ ] day to get drunk yes
see uncle Kerry says the Cuban
sandwiches Ybor City so that's actually
yes you do you live yeah well that's
where that's where the castle is that's
where used together
I live right behind Raymond James
Stadium yeah on MacDill Avenue yeah some
of the more you sauce yes indeed mango
badge it's showing us the flashbulbs
thanks you singing Misamis sing your
praises mango Thank You mango need to
have a [ __ ] drink on the house
Yeah right yeah I mean you know here's a
drink as we drink we just hurt you with
that little drink
yeah Brett Aaron says now I want a drink
it's 4:00 and I'm working for mopes see
that's the nice thing about working from
home yeah like today no boss bring in
Britannia Wednesday at 4 o'clock I'm
just drunk like a whole jar full of
vodka saying ok wasn't completely full
arm DSM are all right before I go in to
eat he's asked question why having DB
cooper first of all a mess are I [ __ ]
order that [ __ ] brand new [ __ ] um
Bravo Company Bravo Company what saqqaq
DCM Bravo company manufacturing h2
buffer for my [ __ ] PSA 16 mid-length
you know I'm talking about I went to
that [ __ ] h2 to give that nearly five
ounces of foot and buffer we try to
smooth that action out anyway see what
happened here the more [ __ ] dirty did
question DB cooper I think DB Cooper
died I think he did too I don't think he
made it
I don't think so either um where he
jumped there was a lot of water
okay I've rappelled out a lot of
helicopters and a [ __ ] know all about
[ __ ] airborne operations you have a
lot of forward momentum during it during
and during a jump
especially jumping out of a [ __ ]
commercial airliner alright so yeah he
might have had his chute deployed
no talent how close to the ground he
deployed the chute if he did it wrong or
not and you have no idea what his
forward velocity was he might have been
fallen to the ground kind of slow but
maybe he was [ __ ] head of forward
velocity 150 miles an hour when he hit
the ground and it may have not have been
ground he probably hit tree limbs and he
was in kind of a [ __ ] moist
environment he might have been busted up
pretty bad by tree limbs and then made
it down into shallow water and with
broken legs and broken arm couldn't keep
his head above water and [ __ ] drown
yeah it's a lot of bad [ __ ] that
happened during a jump it's dangerous I
don't think DB cooper made it I always
kind of I know this isn't what happened
but I always kind of like imagined him
like coming down into the water and then
like he's like yeah I'm gonna make it
and then like a big alligator came up
friend Reza Tatum I understand you know
a civilians gonna have a different
perspective of it jumping out of a
moving [ __ ] jet that jet was probably
moving 220 miles an hour when he jumped
I'm not sure how a [ __ ] shoot would
react to that amount of velocity you
know I'm talking about I'm not real sure
how much he thought he put in not sure
sure if the chute could actually open in
that block I mean and maybe it could but
still I mean they was deployment like
they found some of the money didn't they
yeah I think chances are he [ __ ] it up
and [ __ ] went through tree limbs of
the [ __ ] 150 miles an hour I'm like
you know I fell into one and then fell
in the water he was all in the water
they went
especially with especially with some
broken limbs and and he was he was still
pretty much out in the middle of nowhere
where his where his drop zone was and it
doesn't take much to get lost out in the
[ __ ] a terrain like that and a person
could walk right near your body five
meters away and not see you well yeah
you could all the people that go missing
and like [ __ ] like that I don't think
you know I don't think he made it
I think Chant had he made it he would
have gotten caught in some way he would
have told somebody that he did it or
he would have marked bills or something
something would he got him he would have
ratted on himself from talking too much
about it it's a daring [ __ ] plan very
and and here's the thing was the
smartest plan probably but yeah and I
think he was experienced I think he was
from an Airborne Division I think his
military if I remember correctly yeah I
mean if he wasn't like just doing it
like he did want to put some thought
into it wasn't his first job right I'm
sure he was me he was prior from the
82nd um 82nd Airborne Division probably
not his first job but I don't think he I
don't think he really thought it out in
terms of uh he was jumping maybe like
you know in the back forty or [ __ ]
[ __ ] Fort Bragg but that's not what
the situation was where we reach out
that's not Fort Bragg wasn't it cleared
out [ __ ] drop zone he just took his
chance doesn't weigh that I think and
his only way out of there would be that
he would have a car waiting or some kind
of accomplice and I just find it
unlikely that he could have gotten away
with it yeah I mean even well the thing
about it is that jumping out of a plane
at that I mean even if you accounted for
you know the speed of the plane the you
know the route that the plane was going
stuff like that I mean you're never
gonna know exactly where you're gonna
land so how I mean how would your
accomplice know where to [ __ ] find
you I mean it's like it could be like a
big area he could control his own within
about ten miles probably yeah but I mean
even that that's kind of like a big area
and if he fell and he was wounded like
you said you know you could be walking
around cuz look at all the people that
like disappear and get murdered and [ __ ]
like that and people are like looking
around and don't find him for like years
and years of them later they'd somebody
wanders off like five feet over there
and then they [ __ ] find the [ __ ] you
know what I mean it's like I think
people forget how remote like some
places are and how easy it is to like
miss something as small as like a human
body you know I'm saying there
and where the money is I think the money
is down there with the body well listen
but like I said they did fine here's the
deal
when you're coming down through the
trees at 150 miles an hour chances are
some of that money might go flying out
of whatever bag you got it in and he's
like Oh gets picked up by the wind and
ends up going and goings into the water
they found some of that stuff in the
water some of it buried alongside of the
water but may it not have been buried
originally it might have just ended up
over a few weeks or a few months you
know I mean becoming buried shifting
sands that type of deal didn't they find
some money yeah just there eat a little
bit but it was I don't know if it was
buried but it was like yeah it was like
a little bit it was just a little bit of
it I think it had just gotten kind of
scattered kind of like when you shoot a
bird with a shotgun little feathers the
poof because as I think happens when he
hit those trees you know and all those
little monies we should do a show about
that dude actually cuz he was trying to
find it in the army when you do a job
you're told when to jump cuz the pilot
knows you're over the drop zone right he
knows his forward velocity he knows but
if you if the stick starts to jump out
he knows more or less when they will
drift over the drop zone it's all
computed but that's not that seemingly
not what happened with this job he kind
of knew and had a vague idea of what
time he should jump out of the airplane
based on his course and his speed right
it's very different from looking out
going there's a drop zone yeah that's it
right there okay yeah big idea I don't
know if I'd want to trust just a vague
idea for maybe he didn't maybe the speed
wasn't constant maybe there was a
headwind maybe you know the minute maybe
so there's gonna be a bigger margin of
error mm-hm
he might have jumped out 50 miles away
from where he really should have been 50
miles isn't long 20 miles isn't long
yeah in a plane going nearly 200 miles
an hour so I just I think he [ __ ] it
up yeah and Austin here says I grew up
in that part of the country if he laid
it in the wrong place they will never
find him yeah it's way too easy to get
lost
yeah yeah like I said if you're just a
couple a mile or two like off the mark
yeah
then and no one ever goes out there's
not like anyone's just gonna like wander
past that general area basically is
Dagobah that's what you're talking about
like Yoda and [ __ ] you know I mean like
I said [ __ ] I've written about tons of
cases where you know somebody got
kidnapped and murdered and then their
body was dumped and they didn't find him
for [ __ ] years afterward and there
were there were people around it's just
you know the whole idea mile or so out
in the woods nobody's walking past the
whole idea of finding this man's body in
that environment is a fantasy I told
this story I'm not even this is just
right up the street but I was working
for dr. Matt I could do a damn dead
turkey out the back of the back of his
[ __ ] chicken coop and then forgot to
go bury it you know went back the next
day to go get the get the turkey and
bury it was long gone yeah and that's
when it happened his body did the
chickens murder the turn out there and
that [ __ ] swamp there have been
nothing left of him within 12 hours well
yeah they didn't buy everything in this
kind of environment Laura de we have
like all the animals and all the bugs
it would have been alligators and
buzzards and [ __ ] all kinds of yellow
nothing nothing will leave a dead body
alone especially in the water
yeah it'll be his might as well just
throw it out in the Amazon in the Amazon
so he things don't aren't even around
long enough to rot they're just they're
just eaten yeah too much wildlife can we
spend a moment laughing at because one
weight like I said we were watching the
the Gordon Ramsay uncharted thing and
what they've taken to doing they show
you the show which on Sunday was sumatra
and then they show you 15 minutes of
next week's show I think it's gonna be
in Guyana yeah and so he was there like
the part that they showed he's in this
boat with this
you know Amerindian guy and they're
catching piranhas like to eat them and
it was just like so funny because the
dude I I feel like the whole like behind
the scenes [ __ ] for this show which is
very funny to me was that they just told
everybody that is interacting with
Gordon to just [ __ ] with Gordon as much
as possible so it is they're just like
make fun of him make him do really
embarrassing things make him do really
hard things so he'll fall off the boat
and get wet like make him get behind the
cows and get pulled through the mud and
it's like all this other kind of [ __ ]
like just to make him look like a tool
which i think is but I mean he's a good
sport about it but so him and this guy
are like sitting in this boat and
they're trying to catch piranhas and
poor Gordon they give Gordon the [ __ ]
stick with the string on it and he can't
he's just beating the thing try to get
the piranhas like to come up so you can
catch him and [ __ ] and meanwhile the
other guys like over at the end of the
boat was just a string and he's just
like catching piranhas after piranhas de
ferran and he's just like looking at
Gordon like look up [ __ ] him
aim you are you can't even catch a
single piranha gotta say though they
caught so many piranhas that that is
really not a place where you'd want to
fall into the river I don't even realize
you could eat piranhas but I guess oh
yeah now they're good we're still
forever well I guess because when you
think of piranhas you always think of
them eating you have to be careful about
you eat of all time in Brazil yeah and
like the ones they caught were actually
pretty big and they just what they did
was they just cut him in half and then
he just kind of like you know filleted
like open them off like that and then
the whole come over a [ __ ] grill the
whole piranha thing is [ __ ] they're
not as aggressive as people they know
they're not there it's just because all
those horrible ate my shit's [ __ ]
dying out we gotta say goodbye to
everybody well we've been up yeah we've
been on more language hours and 15 thank
everybody for wishing me a happy
birthday I had a good birthday you guys
were showing me all kinds of flashbulbs
all kinds of good discussions about food
this is just a rambling show doesn't
have anything to do with paranormal
thing or any of the true crime I'm just
a just a fun show that's always the
piranhas aren't always a prize when are
we coming back
it will probably be Saturday and it will
probably be a movie
like I'm putting up like you know horror
stories tomorrow or do we recorded a
movie review like an old movie review
that's going up Friday and then we will
probably be alive again on Saturday and
we'll probably be able so we're gonna do
we're gonna do live movie review on
Saturday on Saturday look at it like a
new movie oh and somebody says new
episodes of unsolved mysteries on
Netflix we definitely have to start her
up over there up now I'm not sure I
didn't see them last night but I wasn't
like looking because like I said I
wanted to get I wanted to watch season
one into a dark again so I could watch
season three but as soon as I'm done
with that we'll definitely start
watching the nuance of mysteries cuz I'm
like super excited about that
alright well see you guys later alright
so we'll see you guys later like I said
we'll be live again on Saturday but
we'll be posting other stuff tomorrow
and Friday so thank you very much
everybody for jarba I can't believe we
went on for such a long time holy crap
and we're so drunk and it's like so
early yesterday no we'll see you guys
later